donc
parce que je vois très bien les plus
dynamique je sais même pas par combien
rémunéré évidemment n'était pas là si
codes ses des habitus et des habitus de
changer un système c'est le meilleur
qu'à des académiques même dans les
aujourd'hui évidemment les dérives dont
zuckerberg qui doudi facebook qui a été
qui ne se sentent plus inclus ceux qui
dit on va de prévoir au planning et
volonté de s'impliquer sur les questions
d'autorité que je suis pas d'accord sur
idiots aujourd'hui tous les jours c'est
donc c'est les mêmes réseaux il faut
dire à la fois dans le côté pur moi
par exemple la france aujourd'hui nous
se passe dans leur boulot de ce qui se
puis après les mêmes politologue disait
essentiel fou qu'on fait partie je pense
compte que mais tu n'es rien
là c'est super super old school de la
sont voilà qui garde les enfants et qui
trois bouquins jean nécessité pas mal
c'est compliqué avancer les soins
faire enfin clore cet épisode de légion
dialectique par le politique il me
j'ai envie de challenge et les agences
exactement je frôle les 4000 euros net
citoyenne individus femme libre
gens trouvent que pas d'abord il ya des
on le transforme
avec goupil ça doit être romain goupil
moyen exactement billy's aux écoles de
politique ou de l'opinion politique
et
d'autres mais
manquent à emmanuel macron
bien sûr de cupidité aussi mais oui mais
part du rail à un peu le mot de
c'est qu'est ce que c'est mal connaître
je ne dis pas qu'il ya pas évidemment
deuxième chose
aujourd'hui ce mix très malsain entre
peu près avec tout le monde et même avec
oublier
milices qui essayent de s'arroger le
commence à avoir peur évidemment sur
avec vraiment des statistiques à l'appui
g voilà
les cadres les cadres moyens je mettrais
question de solidarité il n'est plus
augmentation par un discours sympa par
gens sur la planète donc
tu parles c'est aussi aujourd'hui les
comme greta pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
le rics voilà c'est exactement c'est le
et c'est presque c'est la méthodologie
t'attraper exclusion la d'environ teront
tchèque ils ont leurs ordis ouvert ou
sciences humaines et sociales est devenu
j'ai toujours trouvé les politologues
comme on a un planning à long et moyen
ségolène royal parce que l avait vu des
oui mais mais mais à son usine acelino
passe en chine de ce qui se passe en
sommes de bonnes dettes donc très bien
d auteur complexe aussi on paraît
bien voir ça et ça c'est des milliards
médicaux enfin tous constitution chez
anciennes générations ceux qui sont à la
globale de ceux qui ne font pas partie
de la politique de réclusion vous rendez
et donc du coup je ne sais plus je peux
ce ne sont pas mes cercles
créolisation en fait
comment dire un peu ce
est-ce qu'il faut multiplier et on
que ethniques en france sont interdites
de genre ou d'écologie soit des volonté
que je suis sur le nancy frazer
lecture là on y revient mais la lecture
sentent plus que ça le fait pour eux et
nous ont reproché de ne pas avoir assez
ne peut pas ne pas s'interroger
d'honneur sinon c'était sous la
tout ce travail aussi des femmes et des
sont rémunérés pour cela mal rémunérés
aussi à on sera débarrassé du fn quand
de notation aujourd'hui mais ses
supers déplaisant moi je le remets à sa
on perd tout de suite entre 4 et 5
quand même à peu près évalué à 1400
dans cet aéropage là qui évidemment met
qu'il faut à un moment donné que
lire alors ir pas forcément ce qui est
des valeurs communes
leurs retraites le débat est houleux en
anglo saxons quasiment à 100% donc c'est
les entreprises les moins féministe du
déjà donc je crois que outre je crois
que si le politique de manière malsaine
semble que quand même le retour à la
comment allez vous depuis cette
n'avait pas fait cette multiplication
on résiste on résiste à veut dire quoi
des encouragements mais vous devenez fou
trés trés comme ça
terme il faut que je trouve une date
je trouve que il y à là
les territoires comme on dit aujourd'hui
d'auteur complexe tout à l'heure je
teulet sont en terre etc ou bien on ne
féministes et à la mode que j'ai
ont eu deux fronts tisser ils y tiennent
lapointe solution ces étudiants les
et des milliards et des milliards et des
mais qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est
par exemple dit
tranquille dans son coin privé et puis
justement en ce moment qui est vraiment
ric c'est le tirage au sort bon qui est
7,7 élections locales ce mandat local il
afghanistan de ce qui se passe dans
de soirée de week-end vous voyez ces
surtout que ce brouhaha médiatique
de femmes sur notre
retraite aujourd'hui qui d'ailleurs sont
fabres assises est encore plus parce que
pour que cette cupidité puisque ans
parfois je le redis fermer leur ordi on
par mois avant impôts
choses enfin c'est elle aussi qui
présidence d manueel macron qu'elles
j'arrive à comprendre au fait parce que
légère maladies auto immunes compliqué
de ses plans pour cent et quand je dis
parcours médicaux complètement open
donc mais mes consoeurs et confrères
tellement ça commençait à être
tout cela et c'est tout le job liés au
question que
abyssus économique c'est des habitus
politiques ses politiques si je dis à
monde et puis petit à petit on voit que
mais si demain il n'y a plus les chemins
ça permet de se poser et pas de regarder
enfin voilà quoi non je comprends pas
mais s'empare en fait des codes du
droit de qui tu peux entendre qui tu
alors la personne peut voter front
compte quel
vais jusqu'au bout sur l'état
même les cadres sup en définitive parce
ce moment en france et
autoritarisme
femme à sa place de manière assez ferme
ce bout ce boost bout du marxisme en
et c'est les burnout qu'on connaît
tic car le rogers qui s'inspire beaucoup
anicroche avec guppy comment allez vous
le dire un fait que 7 avril bandz
pense qu'il n'est pas si simple son
réelle et pas juste du gender washing du
j'aime les choses minimale minimaliste
derrière cela c'est intéressant parce
c'était pendant les grèves machin est
ça marche aussi pour eux donc c'est ça
passionnant je relis beaucoup butler je
canton regagne rapidement c'est pas faux
qu'ils que tu chantais déjà je suis sûr
virginie martin bonsoir bonsoir nous
étudiantes bien là dessus on leur en
soins voilà françois c'est l'audi est ce
beaucoup moi je n'ai jamais évidemment
lecture le retour à la lecture
rabbi saoudite nous tiennent au courant
très favorables à la réforme des
justement on parlait tout à l'heure nous
très compliqué pour nous aussi d'aller
entreprises parce qu'elle est en
auraient été remises et je ne voulais
milliards d'argent les fortunes des plus
milliards d'euros par an d'accord sur un
discute c'est plus sympa il était en
milliards de dollars en fonds n'est
veut dire qu'on fait du terrain qu'on va
j'ai besoin de comprendre mais après ce
évidemment s'empare de cela on comprend
fait mourir plus jeunes plus plus tôt
dans la hiérarchie des femmes c'est
raconte la question écologique qui
gisait à se mettre en place et de
vertigineux et on s'était arrêté là donc
le père passera la main à la fille
après il ya mon travail mon travail de
histoire la sexualité est pas si simple
succès politique ça aurait été de dire
donc 3009 on va dire quelque chose comme
aujourd'hui un peu mis en place dans le
sociaux enfin notre bord du a raconté ça
les gens
j'ouvris jouvray une parenthèse sur bois
caire et aux soins qui sont assumés par
et donc ça me demande aussi une hygiène
en disant écoutez pourquoi vous me
greenpeace à la cgt à n'importe qui va
tout un toit
dans la littérature c'est pareil j'aime
complètement chez les dingues ans et
que les cadres sup dépendent encore de
beaucoup écart écorché il ya ce truc que
retraites alors que sont déjà retraités
pas aux questions questions de céline
économique justement des précarités et
que on fait quand même les statistiques
vraiment je ne comprends pas pourquoi et
entreprise qu'est ce qui s'est passé
finalement le système patriarcal ne
y aurait pu comme ça a traîné pendant
elles qui souffrent le plus aujourd'hui
cause leur dit allez voir sur l'ordi la
national la république en marge ps la
suis désolé je me répète un peu
sessions vacances je fais pas partie de
pouvoir pour mieux répondre au pouvoir
non c'est pas faux mais
ce challenge est intellectuellement avec
à saisir et puis foucault raconte quoi
des images jaunies martin merci merci
je le fais pas tu y certains ça me
comment faut il faut il faut il faut
voraces en tulle de voracité j'aime bien
laisse 5 euros eon 10,5 euros c'est quoi
de la psychanalyse on fait de la
quinquennat ça fait vers milliards
fait qu évidemment il ya le capital qui
jugement qui et les arabes et les noirs
la barre très très très très haut dans
et janvier arrive et je vois déjà la loi
dois
j'ai toujours trouvé qu'ils enterraient
aussi que je trouve important hélas
disait que on avait l'impression que
au regard du genre puisque le sexe femme
marguerite duras j'aime quand ça parle
bien aux savanes aux états unis par
gouvernement de manière bien obscur pour
tout d'un coup c'est c'est ce et ses
de fer les cheminots qu'on veut
et puis il ya ceux qui sont en france
tout ça est incroyablement fou parce que
de vie absolument parfaite donc si
grands milliardaires aujourd'hui sont
chercheur tu vois toi peut-être que tu
là je vais faire un grand tube est je
type on a mis trois poules dans la cour
voilà ils sont quand même dans un
parler avec les citoyens et citoyennes
à dix mille fois avant moi mais c'est
c'est plus énorme que des petits états
zy maintenant d'affaires des agences de
que
soumis au système mais qui arrive grâce
retraite enfin c'est quoi l'idée tout ça
aime aussi beaucoup beaucoup l'europe
je reconnais plus rien l'altérité n'est
paraît tellement évident
d'euros à la poubelle très bien
légitimité de webber je voulais cinq
moi quand j'écris ce bouquin en 2014 et
six ans comme maire ou conseiller
ok je vous entends je vous comprends on
quelle naïveté moi j'ai toujours dit là
caste
raconte naïve en boule dans la question
ça voilà et
avec que bill gates qui a monté une
là ça dépend alors ça dépend des
s'appelle singer view nous sommes en
faut lire ce qu'on trouve à la gare non
l'hôpital et de ses urgences dépendent
et mais surtout qu'est ce que c'est mal
et pour mieux exister donc ça c'est très
des femmes de manière ultra précaire
faits là dessus donc c'est quand même
par exemple les ratios de de travail non
des idées des auteurs compliqué mais les
exemple où ces statistiques là sont
absolument casser les tgv les hôpitaux
pas beaucoup mon roman est super
un tirage au sort qui a un peu même
le front national très vite très très
change pas ne mute pas parce que de
du cou et du coup je dis non voilà je
j'aime bien les travaux de thomas
france insoumise elle peut adorer train
notation au regard par exemple de la
aujourd'hui elle n'en a que faire parce
crois la semaine dernière quand il a
système de dépendance de toute façon à
minutes aller voir ça tout seul mais ils
et puis finalement je lui à une deuxième
justement la caste et là tu commences à
les peut-être c'est un peu ado comme
décès cercle l'âge et puis on puisse
résumer le meilleur jeune je rêvais -
psychanalyse ou liliane kandel il ya
big is beautiful ou small is beautiful
qui galère ils nous tiennent aussi au
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
lille britanniques les îles britanniques
là notamment c'était de la
il sort donc en 2015 il ya hollande qui
c'est les femmes c'est les pdc les
est très étrange très ringard c'est nous
intellectuelle tout cela new public
irais pas forcément bouffer avec les
maladie tu as ton employeur va pouvoir
municipal il aurait vu parce que mel
instrumentalisent le travail mais il ya
mais il aime l'europe de jean monnet il
suis désolé de retour à la lecture me
d'un tgv dépendent de l'éducation
plus à reconnaître et je m'en tape
intéressant c'est un peu ce qu'on
très grave c'est extrêmement grave les
deuxièmement pourquoi vous dites que je
va se mettre autour de la table vous
demain quelqu'un me mettais en ecstasy
minimaliste aussi donc j'ai adoré et
manière mal rémunérés alors que c'est
pour ça que je n'aime pas quand ils
venue du politique c'est vraiment
discrimination lisez liées aux origines
que ce pastier c'est bien une décision
idéaux managériaux des années 80 mais
vite selon été très étonné de ça moi
autorisés pour l'instant je pense que
elle peut avoir aimé obama elle peut
de sortir il s'appelle les voraces
enfin j'en passe et des meilleurs les
fondation et reverse sa fortune dans un
n'est pas interdit en france donc là on
contextes et ça je crois que c'est très
connaître la province et le terrain
porcher sur l'économie justement
de démocratie participative
courant et on voit voit une augmentation
adam ont quasi vas-y on est rentré en
beaucoup travaillé là-dessus et c'est
encore spx cet aveuglement armes du
allaient couler en fait dans la manche
aller chercher prendre le temps de
oui c'est sûr c'est sûr que 5 euros
gens du fl de ci de là de là parce que
sont éclairés ils n'ont pas besoin de
responsabilité sociétale des entreprises
que elle peut vivre en fait son lot
parlé aux cheminots qui sont en grève il
justement à cette libération dans
ridiculisé et même moquée par la porte
appelle la théorie de lagence aussi
et puis on a fait un peu voilà on a mis
c'est parce que j'avais plus les voit
série mais je la connais pour l'avoir
dis des conneries
j'aime bien ce mot de voraces parce que
les regarder ton banquier vas pouvoir te
dont les sujets nous intéresse qui
toute façon il perdure il se reproduit à
demandait jean sur le terrorisme quand
cette économie dite libérale qui
politiques eux devrait avoir ce devoir
emmène
machins et c'est juste pas possible quoi
aussi ce patriarcat très capitalistique
aime l'europe qu'ils ont appris dans
leur travail alors évidemment évidemment
d'anvers ou dans la bouche je crois que
même je lui ai simplement cinq mois rsa
compte il dit finalement le vote 30 pour
origine donc double de population
voilà moi mais sert pour les oppriment
maintenant alors moi je suis désolé mais
nationale ils dépendent encore de tout
mets un stop et je dis non voilà mais
fortunes des cliniques privées
moi je ne sais pas boyer jean c'est
fabuleux moi je trouve que c'est d'une
être pour le break site ou contre le
profs et compagnie mais c'est terminé et
ringard à la reagan à la thatcher c'est
entendre parler de mots comme quand je
ça nous emmène là où nous sommes la
tu allais pas forcément envie parce que
avec le break site et ça ne coule pas
des tensions sévère c'est vraiment
c'est à dire que ok tu me mets à la
rémunéré des femmes en occident et des
essentiel pour que ce capitalisme
important
altruisme humaniste s du pipeau pour
laquelle nous étions il n'est plus
disent mais non on mérite non il y en a
économique de la provence et des
revenons à 2006 2007 c'est vraiment
est dans ces oligarchies dans ce pouvoir
politologue c'est un règlement qui l'a
même trempe ne joue pas forcément en
j'ai travaillé des 95 sur les
l'universalisme à les limites qu'on veut
regardée par par par intérêt et
management l'étang entreprise tu n'es
fouiller pas juste lire les notes qu'on
on demande des gens dans l'enseignement
en parlant d' union européenne et en
politique on nous explique que c'est une
portent ces sujets ont fait ce que
semble à plusieurs niveaux mais plus
leur livre il aime l'europe finalement
hétérodoxe
contact début décembre oui mais pas sur
aujourd'hui sont faites sur le dos des
je pars direct dans ces fameuses
comment vous arrivez à les appréhender
une vidéo qu'on m'envoie avec goupil
richesse incroyable alors c'est sûr que
dit je suis très triste
tu n'es rien et je te considères comme
enveloppe kraft on peut en rappel tu as
je suis fan
d'aller lire comme ça plus avant donc la
tu as envie d'une conversation cool et a
commun elle est arrivée à s'en détacher
même du coup est tombé la chemise donc
prêter ou pas donc bien entendu je
parole gouvernement qui tire au sort les
puis après on discute ou enlever au rsa
alors regardez ça bien sûr allons
quand on nageait pas à 300 400 500 mille
que c'est pas que leur taux horaire
c'est un peu ça quand même toujours plus
break 6 que peut être un site voilà
politologue je m'intéresse aussi
bien lui donner un donc l'universalisme
ce que tu fais là évidemment si tu
qui instrumentalisent aussi les femmes
périphérie mais je vais aller prendre
cela même s'ils peuvent monter à des
qui privatise en fait un
l'infini et les mesures est du type les
municipalités en fait était tombée aux
surplombant puissent s'amuser il faut
en syndicats qui évoluent d'heure qui
si je puis dire et
d'hommes et de femmes originaires de
dont ceux des bétons auto lease et voir
territoires pour penser que quelqu'un
c'est difficile de dire non c'est
doublement vraiment et alors là je suis
question que ces gens finalement est
bourdieu avait fait en c'était en
bon alors de sa parole de philosophie
très peu qui sortent de milieux très
évidemment nous a conduits jusqu'au
on peut en france bien sûr bien sûr bien
a fait au dernier moment les éléments de
ce qu'on avait appelé le new public
si vous voulez pénétrer ils en voulaient
intéressant il ya quand même deux choses
et à sant est vieux on parle plus de
ne fais que mon métier en fait j'essaye
quand anton des gens avec lesquels tu
voilà et est aussi est aussi les riches
curiosité intellectuelle c'est le gris
aides soignantes qui gagne rien les
ça vient aussi de notre bonne au réseau
justement j'y vais il ya des choses sur
suis allé au rallye de machin alors le
tout cas je l'espère là dessus je pense
elle ce cépage j'ai fait du mal je je je
pas envie de te poser à ces gens toute
questions sur twitter et qui sont amusé
des codes et je vais m'en servir c'est
mains du front national toulon orange
plus un citoyen plus de vivre ensemble
femmes par exemple en inde pour pour
l'urgence dont je ne reviendrai pas je
rien et en plus je ne vais rien te donne
sévère
toujours plus de pouvoir plus d'argent
prospective c'est l'augmentation dès
une piqûre de rappel et je me suis dit
donc résume la vidéo goupil
disant finalement est-ce que plus on est
qu'essentiel je m'explique alors déjà le
qui combattait la guerre la guerre
difficile de dire non au plateau c'est
regarder ça déjà ça veut dire que le
salaires comme des salaires type cent
sont vos représentants ok très bien
session jusqu'au bout elle fait
les prochaines élections aux états unis
rond je prend parallèlement à l'exemple
management mais c'était le truc le plus
dans toute leur splendeur entre
beaucoup aux questions liées au domaine
décision neutre politiquement parce que
encore droit au pouvoir et à des bribes
dont elle parle enfin les trois choses
sûr
à la française qu'est ce qu'il fait il
enfile il ya beaucoup de bien s'il ya ou
la journée des gens il ya des gens du fn
comprends bien je ne suis pas naïve là
lesquelles je vais avoir du mal parce
l'afrique subsaharienne et de l'afrique
fortunes aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
dit je suis très triste de voir que les
lecture à la fois pour se sauver
n'es pas vraiment d'accord qui votent
capitalisme financiarisé à mort voir ce
crèches à la sortie du bureau sont
euros par an c'est sûr que c'est un
exactement et ça ne coule pas tant que
betty de cette fille mexicaine qui n'a
1990 83,93 marvel plus ce gros bouquin
en revanche que le côté panoptique de
foucault dit c'est quoi ces tendances
chronologiquement on est rentré en
marignane vitrolles est notamment
que tout ça soit assurée de manière ou
oui voilà donc il tombe la chemise et
pendant cinq points pour voir bien sûr
violences ou slam c'est tellement débile
j'ai beaucoup d'espoir dans ce livre et
cypress sur le ca vous a pas échappé que
défavorisés dans ces endroits où qui
est
évidemment donc c'est complètement ja
n'est pas à 10 euros bien entendu bien
citer clairement le pays vend de 1,6
vraiment très tranquille pour le dire
n'étais pas ouvert
ok bon je remplis je remplis le truc
serait finalement plus utile pour moi
rallye c'est quand on vous fait
de garder mon calme ce qui n'est pas
ça nous mène à quoi cette déconnexion du
films on parle de série de concerts de
etc qu'est ce que c'est si ce n'est
pense pas à cause de l'ecstasy mais à
sécession on dit toujours que les
corrigeons ça des valeurs saisonnières
moi je trouve pas ça rigolo du tout
gros plus haut et fort et bien c'est pas
difficile de dire non vous savez c'est
qui sont je dis pas qu'ils sont passés
c'était étonnant car même les voraces
aussi un moment donné le phénomène queer
sur ces choses là mais on est ouvert à
il ya beaucoup de merde aussi mais tu
qui me qui me tient à coeur aux le
fou du monde c'est comme ça que la
de la sociologie et aussi au domaine de
guillemets
corps où je veux bien croire que ce
enfin des crèches le soir pour que les
contact début décembre
typiquement dans cette affaire je trouve
dans les industries de la mode par
front national quitte excuses des choses
des dj les jeunes justement
du nord et l'a donc là il ya bien de la
présenter entre gens de la bonne société
c'est ils ne font plus de terrain c'est
mais mais le maître rsa cinq mois ça
c'est donc il fait son grand show man
qu'ils combattaient le nazisme cette
tu serais contre ta propre philosophie
mille euros par an d'accord qui ferait
un visibilis d'accord c'est sa volonté
politique dit à ses investisseurs comme
dessus un jeu du diable voilà non mais
ça donc il faut aussi alors nous
mais je vous entends je vous veux et je
bah en fait je suis invitée
évident évidemment dans ces cas là
banlieues ont fait sécession franchement
vois bien qu'il travaille un peu ça peut
particulièrement avec un gros focus sur
pourquoi pas allons-y et puis après ça
questions de solidarité de générosité
donc les ratios sont délirants et même
gratuites ou très peu et très mal
stratégies ou je ne sais qui ou là ce
féminisme évidemment salle on parle
enfin la démocratie ce n'est pas un truc
elle est obligatoire dans leur délire
aussi excuse moi de revenir là dessus
sortent de milieux qui sont hors de ces
cause de l'état d urgence a dit que les
en mai mais on discute pas politique
effectivement
je dis je prend le contre-pied très
que tout d'un coup c'est l'éthique qui
hills va y avoir des gens qui attendent
complètement du pipeau et il ya quelque
intéressant et aussi oui ce n'est
que n'importe quel autre vote c'est
tous et aucun problème mais par exemple
oligarchiques elles font quoi en fait
comme aussi beaucoup de jeunes filles
exemple pour ne pas les citer et de
politique qui brasse de l'air chaud qui
pas les canons de beauté et qui va
vois ce que je veux dire quand je dis ça
parce que tu avais vu des trucs chez
je ne travaille pas sur sur la
qui fait mille pages à peu près qui
un peu dur tu vois à bon il faut il faut
donc c'est complètement dingue leleu
entendu il peut être à 53,60 je ré ouvre
aux états unis france et dans des années
chez les journalistes
europe là et qu'ils combattaient
sur 40 bornes ou prendre un bus sur
d'une manière m'avait laquelle mouchetés
c'est un élevage oui c'est oui c'est un
comme ça et
rigolo quoi on peut être cool on peut
sécurité sur les chemins de fer en
notre surveillée de notre société de
sur toulon et
sera difficile de l'inscrire dans la
mais voilà tu m'aimais si tu avais honte
régulièrement sur le 24 heures pujadas
les banlieues des banlieues très dur je
de ce temps qui va trop vite et du
et edouard philippe non il n'est pas
rock donc je regarde
du alors puisque vous demander par mois
évidemment c'est notre métier de
capitalisme de la libye oui et puis même
je ne suis pas naïve mais n'empêche que
moi qui habite est très très longtemps
ça qui nous gouvernent finalement ben
et il continue il continue il continue
nette de un certain alain finkielkraut
deux jeunes femmes ont du mal aussi à
au sein de nos sociétés occidentales les
rémunérés donc ça c'est la première ça
l'économie et des sciences de gestion
tout il dit je suis jupiter je suis
rejoindre magazines de mode et ça va
pourquoi les féministes ont pas fait des
n'est plus que les crimes de légumes de
que les gie les jeunes étaient
ça suit son cours et puis quand il a été
femmes puissent gérer leur leurs enfants
constitution ma proposition est
sociologie des médias la sociologie des
évidemment mais souligné aussi mais on
en fait donc ce serait problématique
les ministres ouf le rouge pour lors des
80 90 qui dit
alors les riceys cette case a rossé 1%
s'appelait la misère du monde
peut-être pas peut-être pas assez
première c'est à dire que moi je ne suis
comme pour moi un centime d'euro je
racontent n'importe quoi qui parle omar
vais vous respecter et je vais
elle est passée radical pétition bil'in
nous et et moi j'avais apprécié la façon
angleterre c'est complètement cassé la
chercheur de travailler le plus possible
simple comme bonjour
tu vas voilà on est d'accord ça veut pas
l'armement et qui après aussi font de la
très grande surveillance peut évidemment
cercles il y en a peu très peu
hôpitaux en france est devenue 10 et
technocratique financiers économiques
y avoir des milliardaires à la source
avaler
alors le le brésil bonjour j'ai fait
elles privatise le savoir et elles vont
complètement dingue de penser ça et
voilà nous on est arrivés par des biais
me choque on n'est plus dans le
ça de faire de 8000 net par mois
voit là mais la démocratie c'est une
de solidarité inter générationnelle
quelque chose la lecture et le moment du
il disait à l'époque c'était la grande
légumes qui restent non revenir à la
donc cette neutralité économique
marseille ont plus les banlieues
comme on dit vous avez fait un peu de
insisté sur sur ce que j'appelle dans le
peut-être plus réaliste pour la
sur lci et donc il y a régulièrement
journalistes du politique et la
non vous allez plus jouer ce juste entre
chaînes youtube toute femme pour se
qui dit l'identité malheureuse et moi je
comprendre et là on va trouver des
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a fait des
alors je regarde comment
une parenthèse si vous permettez
débats aujourd'hui recoins c'est quand
chez lui est intéressant avec deux
n'est plus tout à fait à cette époque
pareil quand j'ai fait mes long
celui qui sait quand j'ai d'or philippe
et je dis bah voilà non non je ne suis
chose de plus radicale à penser dans par
aussi qu'il travaille à ça et je ne sais
être très dur pour elle est évidemment
figure enfin c'est thatcher qui a fait
c'est une démocratie qui aurait connu
pas une femme je suis un citoyen
politique on est dans l'éthique et la
c'est le premier pendant mais après le
ils ne font plus de terrain et je peux
verticaliser et je vais rester
parle a vraiment envie de citer très dur
ce capitalisme de plateformes enfin
femmes racisées sont aussi toujours en
mieux et puisse rester à la réunion plus
dire qu'ils ne sont pas sympas que
scroll mais la lecture aussi et
élevage alors j'ai de moins en moins oui
constitution mais tu as même quelqu'un
vraiment
question que le procès s'était quasiment
cher donc comme tu le disais
heures et des heures et des heures
pense que c'est à peu près ça mais la
oman ans avec sa petite perruque en les
compliqué méthodologique a passé un peu
ok tu dis que je suis un et bien
à lui de nous contacter et donc on avait
histoire sérieuse
on parlait tout à l'heure mais aussi
développent très très longuement et de
pas c'est des gens que j'ai moins moins
mode du journalisme et c est donc comme
la série culte que je conseille la mes
à une forme de neutralité de plus
aujourd'hui de toute façon être
donc l'europe aujourd'hui est ce que
là je le montre pas du doigt au sens
vous mais le problème aujourd'hui c'est
réapproprier inversée faire se secoue de
entretien à la revue politique et
le transformer en pouvoir c'est comme ça
est ce que c'est ce cadre supérieur à
français points mais quand je subisse
sociologie du politique oui bien sûr la
très très peu donc typiquement quand
l'être humain n'est pas sympa mais tu
capitalisme une fois et c'est ce système
là il parlait de la retraite n'intéresse
verticaliser essais d'autorité dont vous
je la comprends pas je la comprends pas
scission avec bruno mégret et tout le
c'est dramatique c'est dramatique et
même c'est quand même dingue il ya plus
tard etc voilà pour moi tout ça c'est du
bas de cette échelle des femmes dont on
une fabuleuse opportunité politique une
lecture aussi d'auteurs compliqué notons
s'appelle-t-elle patty hewes cela je
d'entretiens avec les plus misérables
voilà je pense que là on parle vraiment
soi-disant sont déjà dans la ville dont
solutions on va trouver des solutions
c'est ce et voilà ces économies
qui a pris en fait moi je suis donc
de la casse sociale c'est à ce moment là
parce que je pense qu'on a à un moment
il s'est par exemple à marseille vous
parle d'identité au contraire pluriel
problématique pour tout le monde
non ce stade ça s'appelle un choix
ceux qui sont à 300 400 500 mille euros
calme la lecture est le moment de
enfin en voie de finalisation il y à
prospective sur la radicalisation des
discuté d'un certain une bonne heure non
assez dit non alors j'y suis allé et
manière très savante d'ailleurs et est
le répéter alors là pendant trois jours
parlementaire où je suis allé vraiment
bouquin dont je parlais tout à l'heure
fais pas le même travail tu as donc
que kiki qui se serait évidemment croisé
je sais très bien qu'il travaille à ça
comme nicolas sarkozy maire de neuilly
l'imaginaire et l'imaginaire la
étudiants dans mon nom mon programme
disant là t'es bien gentil postaux de la
aussi
un ministre qui peut aller se promener
qu'il ya aussi une élite que taux
l'éthique c'est quoi ces noms à 2,3
quelques allusions de trois fois tout à
parce qu'en effet c'est pas que vous
et non parce qu'on a vu que les juges
invité à la table on est quatre
sur ce monde qui nous échappe sur faire
parle donc on voit bien à quel point ces
pas d'accord et on ne dit pas que je dis
sociologie du politique c'est vraiment
sais plus enfin j'adore ces scandales
exemple la fin de ce patriarcat il faut
statistiques ethniques ou pas je veux
étudiée que les gens de la classe
que ça se passe il ya un politologue du
possible d' objectivité je dis pas qu'on
monde disait ça va s'arrêter vous
gender washing et là c'est du pipeau
soins médicaux
ça font des injonctions aux femmes
que ken lochte a fait ses films en
dans les fourches caudines est arrivé à
voilà donc je veux vraiment revenir et
puis j'ai continué elle m'a pas assez
finalement elle nous aide face aux à la
judokas de s'approprier et de fermes y
avez besoin vous jour de rien vous gens
je suis pas d'accord avec ça je suis pas
les à elles font peu sécession et mais
pour bien moi je pense aussi comprendre
avez quand même la cité pia qui est dur
endroit où il n'y a pas de métro puis
c'est pas les mêmes circonstances en
par an ce genre de choses qui
du pc à la france a soumis than allant
j'arrive à sciences po
hybride est très heureuse justement en
aussi la question écologique était quand
maintenant je vais faire je vais relever
plus personne
des discriminations ou du sexy ce où que
l'absolu et les autres qui ne savent pas
on peut pas dire que c'est là qu'est les
moi je suis révolté en tant que
patriarcal en fait qu'ils jouent tout ce
prospectives sa radicalisation n'ont pas
spécial médias qui est la série mad men
donné
fabuleuse opportunité pour qu'ils nous
banque tu n'es rien tu l'as pas compris
d'entre nous mais pour ça il faut y
politique de se priver de 20 milliards
créativité on n'a pas parlé de
autre question d'arpenteur est ce que la
l'heure alors d'abord en tant
avec des ddc c'est très net fixe est
des conneries on dit je ne suis pas
ce que ça nous interroge pas aujourd'hui
peut-être un beau but même et et et j'ai
qu'un auteur compliqué c'est quoi alors
lentilles burnout la lecture permet de
inquiétez pas à le fn va mourir à cause
fumez ont des mains mais le grand débat
voilà c'est une indécence et c'est vrai
ait pas on parle pas d'un endroit on est
d'appels et j'aime bien ça stato
plus grande pauvreté en france mais même
pour que j'utilisais le moulin jeudi 10
observateurs et romain goupil qui fait
et je suis pourtant la bonne élève et
libérales nous ont pas pu mieux peu à
d'être toujours plus si toujours plus
extraire de tout cela des chiffres forts
dit non et où elle n'a pas dit elle n'a
najat vallaud belkacem qui était à
fait moi j'ai pas de problème à parler
et qu'ils sont certainement sincère
aller plus vite plus fort de manier et
donné du crédit déjà au monde de
la cité de la castellane qui dure vous
même au centre de ce qu'elle voulait
après reprendre un bus de ville où je
politique je pense qu'il ya les vieux
qui il reste des dents pour plagier mais
disant mais qu'est ce qu'on est en train
c'est pour ça que l'économie hétérodoxes
d'accord avec vous c'est différent on ne
prêts matic et le capitalisme joue de ce
avec une forme de dictature oui c'est
siècle dernier qui racontait sa très
créativité ils ne sont plus créatifs
d'accord j'ai même pas que je n'aime pas
qui ne sont rien
d'entretiens c'est aussi j'ai pu aussi
chercheur que les politologues des
mondialisation on est à l'acte ii à
quittent pour le politique en place pour
dire on peut aujourd'hui dire où vous
psychologiquement mais cassez cassez
commun entre clown j'ai appelé ça comme
vous voyez c'est aujourd'hui parler
capitalisme mais qui s'amuse avec cela
là en revanche la caste des 1% a fait
sais de quoi je parle et je sais très
arrogante péremptoire
valeur pour moi
dire comme quelqu'un comme martine aubry
de faire de ce pays quoi et qu'est ce
jeunes à huy le jeunisme aussi j'avais
ce poste castoriadis c'est compliqué ça
n'est pas excusé
de juifs
soit disant tu as tu prends ça comme une
de la scission mais moi je faisais du
l'époque ministre de l'éducation
qui est une histoire à partir des années
véritablement enfin ça dépend de quel
aussi des individus mais on a aussi
financière moi j'adore ce truc parce que
disant mais finalement le mur de berlin
jusqu'au front national
peu amener à ça et nous qui sommes danse
si vous me posez une question et je
payer ont bien sûr mais bien sûr parce
je me fait assassiner en tant que femme
mois ça parce que ça permet de
je viens de parler là très supérieure
d'euros il y a eu des gens qui payent
sais pas où je sais pas quoi un moment
parce que tu es trop bête ou des choses
lui a nui ou si tu as quand même des
de manière plus plus plus entière en
politique le choix vis-à-vis de la
pas crié à seynod et du coup j'ai fini
bien soit les tendances oligarchiques
aller et il faut pas juste tomber la
qu'analyste je je je n'ai jamais crier
pensent qu'ils sont méritants
l'acte iii de la mondialisation où est
nationale et
le côté justement france forte
boris johnson a quand même bien réussi
êtes allé vous êtes revenu qui est ce
très très jeune beaucoup d'argent
en a il ya notamment les couilles sur la
l'ajout de ce travail invisible joue de
l'art moi j'ai commencé en faisant la
oublié toujours plus jeunes toujours
moi j'ai grandi à une époque quand j'ai
que fait tim cook aujourd'hui je ne sais
avez dans des villes voilà comme paris
insulte et bien maintenant moi je vais
comprendre n'est pas dire ok bravo est à
l'internet à son côté un peu friendly à
tu vois il notamment dans le cadre de
plus faible le sexies déjà pour moi
aussi qu'on a loupé pour une 1 point de
terrain j'entendais les gens j'ai fait
vous
des partis politiques il raconte en fait
radicalisation est ce qu'on parle
cela le clan des clones en fait ces gens
certain avec aussi des altérités aussi
que c'est le new public management c'est
juge pas
gens qui sont en situation de handicap
réponds à côté il ya quelqu'un d'autre
évidemment de quoi at-il besoin une fois
encore comme à l'ancien temps de dire
sociologues etc ils pas tous évidemment
partie de ces gens est de soixante
guerre économique ah oui moi je le crois
bien de quoi je parle pour le coup
peut être judith butler est très
serra qui réussit son sursaut donc avant
rencontrer comme j'avais bien compris
journaux et blanc du cheval blanc je ne
en en passant par et cetera et cetera
s'évader de se reposer
maintenant c'était c'était comme ils
et dort philippe nous dit je resterai
que tout ça a un coût tout ça a un coût
par bah oui tu as une plainte pour viol
faire la communauté gay et je vais te
donc on va aller généralement ils sont
donné ou faire du stop
ce que finalement elle nous ennuie dans
voit là est tombé en 1989
les sf qui se sont retrouvés avec des
son brac site et il sera smoltz en tout
voilà vous êtes pas dieu vous êtes
que vous avez vu acquis ou est-ce que
plus minces toujours mieux habillées
macro évidemment n'a pas su saisir cela
autoritaire de
compliqué judith butler est très
stato financière évidemment c'est quoi
exactement
malheureusement assez plate forme et je
m'approcher quand même des hommes
complètement sécession et finalement
qui sont au chômage qui trouvent pas de
puisque
comme ça ça nous emmène ou à la guerre
du côté de l'économie hétérodoxe
d'économistes dans les plateaux télé
peuple qui coûte un pognon de dargah
chemise devant un parterre de
50 jusqu'à aujourd'hui enfin pas si
table qui sont effectivement là pour le
mon travail apprécié pas de prêt si je
s'est on peut plus se sortir de cela
voilà en tout cas où on en a besoin et
oui il faut faire de la pédagogie pour
son programme notamment sur le caire
mondiaux au secours à un peu plus loin
peut-être pas assez bien mais aussi on
voter fn c'est le meilleur et je
raconter comment je vais être fiers
j'ai eu parce que j'ai pas mal de
oui
le parti politique est un truc tellement
au loup j'ai plutôt analyser
tant que femme parce que femme tout d'un
se ressemblent complètement et ils font
commencé à m'intéresser aux questions de
ce que la proposition d' emmanuel macron
calés à plus de 120000 euros par an à
qu'est ce qu'on fait de gens aussi qui
compliqué elle est très complexe et elle
fait et ces mesurettes ne servent à rien
ces femmes ainsi visibiliser et non
huitard à la condamnent dit qui se sont
sais pas en tout cas ce jeu je dois
j grosse épidémie en régions en france
cesser ces valeurs là que j'ai france
je faisais des lettres moi j'étais très
alors voilà ça c'est un grand mystère de
cet acte 2 3 de la mondialisation donc
chèques qui arrivait chez eux de 20000
elle est à la fois étatiques et
mais aussi toujours sexualisé au delà de
civile ça nous mène à un état policier
que tout ça est pris en ligne de compte
grande illusion c'est ça la grande
d'entretiens avec des gens qui votaient
d'arrêter le temps d'une certaine
pour parler comme les chercheurs ou de
j'ai été touché le moment exactement
intimement parce que quand même
d'être homo et comme tu dis et tu
son côté sympa à son côté allé un peu et
premier ministre et je vais aller me
comprends pourquoi tu l'as fait non je
s'appellent laissant dans celle et
mais je trouve que le léger les jeunes
elle fait sécession aussi au regard des
pense que c'est pas toujours bien mais
nous avons que des économistes libéraux
de la loi font que de la moquette
voilà le la droite
pratiquement des publicitaires
c'est insupportable ce n'est pas
compliqué aux cédants dansez dansez
des alternatives qui ne sont plus donné
boulot qui se sont fait larguer par
donc ces politiques de soins et elle
nous on a beaucoup travaillé justement a
n'est pas celui-là pour le peu que j'en
c'était tout à fait content tu as même
suis ami avec quelqu'un qui votent
clan et il pense que c'est
coup je rends bien que je suis moins
cas
financière mais c'est à dire aussi que
de manière plus ou moins consubstantiel
conseillers municipaux
il a besoin de s'amuser de se distraire
non mais c'est aussi c'est aussi des
que le peuple nous comprennent mais de
cesser les travaux d'esther duflo a
coup des chaînes qui sont très féministe
au départ
convertis au maquereau nisme et
très dures et dont beaucoup disent oui
peu près mais je pense que là la classe
illusion donc là au lieu de faire ça
front national et je vais fait aussi des
pas encore faire de la pédagogie pour
avouer que ma position de chercheuse me
lantheaume typhon alors non il n'ya pas
etc et là je trouve que dick s'est
boris johnson comme quelqu'un quand même
est dans un système américain qui n'est
à un moment donné
m'en moque de ça moi je voulais
présenter au havre en même temps qui est
manière d'imaginer
est sacrément complexe
j'ai pas ont des horaires décalés des
donc cette société quand même et
j'aime aussi voir ses séries comme
reconnue en fait et tout ça et laissait
imaginons un intrus qui arriverait deux
ça nous permet nous de dire des choses
leurs entreprises qui sont dans la
smaller than before
saussines soulagement fou et ça me pour
aujourd'hui je comprends la question est
c'est très étrange on dit des choses
de neutralité épistémologique de rupture
c'est pas ça où il faut chez gaultier où
fourre-tout 5e que j'ai pas vu que j'ai
sûrement empêché de travailler sur
françois hollande c'est ça pour plagier
ça c'est un autre c'est une autre
développe c'est à dire l'état je lui
tolérable je ne peux pas passer ces arcs
qui est actuellement dans la société
payés parce que femme je suis bien dans
ma vie
d'universalisme non et c'est pour ça que
c'est je voulais faire mon mémoire de ce
court on parlait beaucoup de vivre
et là que fait-il et bien ce système
50 en dix mois axe de toute façon elles
ça nous mène à plus de dialogue social
donc la radicalité
infrastructures par exemple
new-yorkais qui sont sur madison avenue
comprendre les
que je comprenne ça va pas marcher ça ne
connais
lé financière mais elle déteste la
rse responsabilité sociale de
disait il faut que le caire soient
quand même eu le prix nobel l'année
alors c'est très marrant ce une liu
pas quand même la commune la plus petite
gainsbourg mais j'étais était ravie moi
web explose c'est génial on va arriver
il arrive vite chez moi le le nom est
misère qui sont pas heureux qu'ils sont
c'est quoi c'est une demande de
panoptique mais voilà si on parle du
évidemment évidemment qu'à une des
vois c'est comment tu tu renverses le
light ou pas
question aussi et donc le break si tu
on n'entend plus rien on n'entend plus
la lecture permet aussi
donc c'est quand même très étonnant
règlement intérieur comment tu prend le
qu'ont les gens
est de mieux travailler bien sûr
quel peuple par le ton on est plus fort
pas avec ségolène royal ça c'est certain
et
bien passé je n'ai pas cassé mon amitié
nancy fraser chez les féministes est
cercles tu vois les cercles fermés dans
chines bizarre qu'on mettrait à
c'est pas de la prospective
heures et des heures d'entretiens avec
dernière elle est française on ne se
dont je parle c'est vraiment plus haut
pas le même et là ces milliardaires aux
elle me semble être effectivement
que de la moquette mais il n'ya pas que
horaires de nuit
il faut pas aller tout simplement sur
euros de remboursement je sais pas si
dix soirées avec moi au bout de deux
j'ai appelé mon bouquin le sous titre
de france premier ministre s'est pas
vraiment au coeur des programmes
et et romain goupil sur le plateau que
sont plus bonne à rien je me nicole
ronaldinho blaquart ça a commencé avec
et la ona
ressorts de cela comme je voulu
sensées il me semble et les mêmes on dit
l'entreprise on s'est dit qu'ils
il ya des podcasts très intéressant qui
françois hollande laissant donc le cadre
relativement vie c'était manuel valls
puissances financières
de plus malin que la caricature qu'on
concurrence parce qu elle verrouille
tu vas même la même sarkozy quelque part
truc alors c'est vrai aussi chez
mais en tout cas voyons plutôt de
ensemble de citoyenneté
imposé d'un bien moi plus pop il a dit
épistémologique tout ça on est obligées
permet
des gens qui étaient anti front national
ces gens lait frais qui prennent pas
mais il y aura des réseaux le réseau
politiquement mais je pense qu'elle
c'est très bien je m'explique c'est très
se moquent complètement des systèmes
des statistiques que la république une
cash son cloche rappelez-nous encore ça
alors quand ils sont vraiment
politique s'il vous plaît
sécession et c'est très bien pour une
accorderait pas le mode start up l'état
malheureusement c'est ce qu'on vit tous
qu'après dans cette société je le répète
alors que je répète il aurait eu il à
point de vue de la sociologie vous savez
patriarcal va mettre quoi on route est
va pas marcher donc voilà j'ai pas 12
je lisais père est que toute la journée
la moquette et des petits fours y en a
que ça encore ces trois cent mille par
sans on n'est plus dans les années 50
délirante
vas nous faire voir si effectivement on
lesquels on est coopté c'est très
pouvoir comment tu fais les l'émotion
de ne pas faire partie de ces réseaux
de le faire et donc on écoute beaucoup
marseille avec ses à carry le rouet qui
l'universalisme des différences j'ai dit
au regard de cela alors après moi j'ai
de ne plus être sur instagram sur
apadooraï pour les populations noires
ça où on voit des femmes justement en
politiques et je trouve que c'est quand
compliquée les féministes sont
tout avec des lois étatiques d'accord
positif cl démocratie participative
allaient apporter avec la démocratie la
les bords d'un canal trouvé de sdf en
normalement une occupation à quart-temps
qui ont très bien réussi
économistes en plus sain parce que la
kidman vie dure et voilà est exactement
états unis viennent aussi compenser
managériale enfin le coût
deux manières consubstantielle à cela
comprendre pourquoi les politiques
pour ont fait bien des statistiques au
leur voiture en face le débat avrillé
marguerite duras j'analyse est disséqué
marrant cette histoire de débats et de
compliqué le et là je parle aussi en
boutades sexiste voilà ça m'est
mais je voyais bien que les anti fn
qui devait me la remettre je n'ai pas eu
sont aujourd'hui sortis en plus son
les jours donc de ce point de vue là si
mais on a très peu il n'y en a il y en a
c'est extraordinaire on vous conseille
que les les mesures du gouvernement
de volonté générale de commun où sont
met d'accord ça devrait nous amener tout
je ne connais pas du tout un par
faisait de lui la plupart du temps donc
compliquées généralement la lecture des
difficile c'est un peu comme si tu étais
recherche sur gainsbourg la sorbonne m'a
médicaux
tout ça c'est super vieux aussi je suis
qui l'y a évidemment ceux dont on
lui raté évidemment mais une occasion
même des choses qui à mon avis serait
enfin je sais même pas de quelle époque
plupart du temps ils sont pas forcément
logiciel ne vont pas les logiciels ne
ok on peut avoir on peut avoir un socle
on embrasse beaucoup de points de vue de
an ces cinq cent mille par an et après
finalement sortir et des zones de
plein en powerpoint comme dirait judith
vous voyez le délire dans lequel on est
c'est pour ça qu'il parle aussi de
tombe complètement à plat quand on sort
évidemment la halle c'est un travail
importante alors est ce qu'après ça doit
et indivisible
bien la femme alors l'a pas vue comme
entreprises la start up c'est trop sexy
l'union européenne le réseau du
avait eu un peu de contact avec la vraie
réinsérer moi s'il vous plaît je veux en
grands débats étaient super super super
puisqu'elle n'en sont pas tributaires
démocratisation du savoir le wikipedia
etc et c'est qu'au bout d'un moment de
petit fascicule petit bouquin il me
disent et pensent qu'il pense pourquoi
ailleurs vous connais pas non plus qui
mais en plus ils ont de toute façon des
non pas un chute et en plus alors en
évidemment non c'est pas ça c'est que
même des fulgurances politique que ce
blouson en cuir des années 80 j'ai entre
quelques mois j'ai peut-être des peut
partie ce n'est pas complètement faux
est bien obligé de regarder en face et
il parle parce que ces gens sont quand
10 je l'aimais rien réussit alors à
comme rêve de côtoyer le vrai bourgeois
waouh quand même quoi dont maquereau ou
j'étais la plus heureuse et puis me
rappelez-vous quelques milliardaires ont
toujours sur ces histoires de fabriquer
et ce magnifique texte où on ne verra
désolé de revenir là dessus sur sur
c'est ça dont on parle en effet la
d'un bond en mauvais manager management
donc en fait aller c'est une finance
vont pas du tout est par exemple pour la
était plutôt dense que j'avais appelé à
c'est des millions et des millions et la
ça c'est un premier point maintenant
créolisation à comment ils reprennent
regard du genre comment on sait
aux américains de soucis c'est pas mal
celle qui fabrique des êtres humains qui
mais on peut aussi être différent et
mais aussi hybride complexe un peu un
photoshop sur les réseaux sociaux toute
plus efficace à moyen terme typiquement
très envie que manuel valls la rom est
et on nous raconte que
ce don qui les cinéastes
tant que femme t'as bien vu le switch
cas moi c'est ce que j'appellerais donné
ans et quand bien même j'en aurai 16
butler
historique de faire et de refaire de la
confinement imaginons on peut plus faire
m'enfin je trouve que le débat a
semble que je suis fort un parc gérard
puisqu'elles ont évidemment leur médecin
ne l'a pas entendu tout le monde s'en
cette société panoptique de très grande
parlait tout à l'heure génial la dette
commonwealth le réseau du grand large
dit on paye pas assez d'impôts on paye
les gilet jaune pensent ce qu'ils
dans l'imaginaire des gens c'est qu'on
sa part c'est évidemment des pinots cd
de si simple rancière peut être
insupportable
mais justement au bout d'un moment c'est
en plaine en powermat kiki qui prennent
aujourd'hui que les femmes sont
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
toute façon il ya plus que les grands
nationalisée elle qui déteste les
drôle enfin je les ai tenus jeudi sept
c'est ça et il prend les mêmes codes il
violence et les tensions en fait cette
de l'union européenne et est ce qu'on
thatcher par exemple qui disait à
soit le caire chez martine aubry le
veux si je pouvais a plus de politique
enfants on pourra aller faire trois
vie
effectivement plus jamais nicole kidman
qu'on veut qu'on ce qu'on veut exhaustif
être je veux faire partie de ce commun
les codes des blancs dominant pour
ils ont été pris nous avons été pris
comme je le disais le break site va
options libérales donc moi qui arrive de
faire valoir ses diversités dont cet
interdit de faire ce jeu me suis
résultats je me fais la beauté du diable
privés dont les gie les jeunes vol aux
l'accès libre et ça c'est vrai pour une
des humains ce sont aussi des femmes qui
deux voilà on va ce challenge et on fait
donc ça c'est difficile pour moi est
complètement complètement complètement
là tout d'un coup je ne suis plus un
plus il dit non mais en plus si je suis
revue politique et parlementaire j'ai
avoir des amis qui votent fn ou qui on
être
éclairée du parti qui peuvent de toute
en france on sait à peine par qui elle
leurs yeux évidemment parce
discriminées au niveau des salaires
les éduquent etc mais comme la femme
est un coût important et en coût réel et
mais en revanche j'étais assez contente
surveillance bien sûr que c'est
face à ça c'est pas possible le
pensent aujourd'hui ils font ce qu'ils
coule ou est-ce qu'on fait couler aussi
je suis toujours mal à l'aise avec cette
que j'ai fait un sur sur le nom le long
américain donc finalement small is
voilà je n'en sais pas plus moi non plus
tape alors que c'est bien elle qui
l'époque there is no alternative c'est
privé leurs cliniques
alors il ya évidemment la radicalité
arnaud cesser ces gens là ont donc assez
noms même drôle de manière cynique si on
pas assez d'impôts il faut qu'on paye
citoyen français mais une citoyenne
photos qui passeront peut-être dont
l'économie la finance la rationalité
compliqué
vieillir mais on n'a pas vu donc plus
de la pub voilà
ambiance très tendue qu'on peut voir
qu'aujourd'hui s'estime aussi voir kaka
quelque chose d'impérissables qui
vrillé et on n'a plus entendu l'essence
élu mais que je reste prémunissons
d'autres questions internet pourquoi
c'est parce qu'on a bien fait des
peut avoir des amis qui sont pas de deux
l'impression qu'ils sont devenus
trouvé intéressant aussi un peu comme
que maman donc le mérite il est déjà un
pouvoir aussi peut-être en temps réel
tu vois genre je suis très anti front
problématique mais je pense que voilà si
prend les mêmes attitudes est ce que
comme ça les devants qui sont des femmes
politique de redonner tous et
personnel hospitalier évidemment est
est détenue on sait à peine heureusement
l'écologie c'est que ségolène royal la
j'ai pas du tout envie de faire
on veut donner la parole à tout le monde
nationalisations donc c'est une finance
époque où effectivement faisons de la
des impôts il faut qu'on travaille
avalé par un système et nous sommes
comme objet de séduction et là il va lui
justement avec un grand p ce politique
universalisme un auteur que j'aime bien
justement aller
façon prendre le partie d'accord et ça
bien sûr et puis ça change non mais dans
et des hôpitaux de très grandes
sont le plus souvent aides soignantes
l'infrastructure l'infrastructure du
statistiques au regard du genre d'accord
intellectuellement et on va pas toujours
raconte les trappes exclusion les
du corps etc c'est difficile et est
sciemment je démissionnerais etc enfin
que j'intègre est là et bien quand même
jeunes fonda vieillir parce que tout du
restera sur les réseaux une bouteille à
des fortunes en milliards vous voyez que
rédhibitoire
scroll en fait quoi et la lecture de ce
finissait par être drôle ça il vaut
vous le faites ici de donner la parole
plutôt de l'économie hétérodoxe je suis
voici gala c'est délirant quoi alors
dont je parle moi je suis d'un féminisme
diable d'abord
une partie de l'union européenne
j'ai pas d'action dans dans le marché
justement au destin du pays les
aujourd'hui dans la société m'interpelle
ringards alors que justement pour parler
avez vous accepté la légion d'honneur en
partie c'est vrai mais néanmoins on sent
passionnant où les femmes auprès
crevé et c est là dessus sur sa par
sécession c'est encore possible de
dans un vraiment un aspect à la fois de
que najat vallaud belkacem me remettre
moi j'aime aussi marie-hélène bourcier
française est là il faut il faut que
de ce que je veux dire c'est tout et
que c'est pas juste pour faire plaisir
noires
d'état c'est une finance nationaliser
le racisme est rédhibitoire et même des
pas politiquement correct trop alter
infirmières
démocratie participative
récupérer des bouts de pouvoir c'est ce
savoir qui mois de prison sous la halle
national mais bon repas ce mois du
plutôt des victimes dans cette histoire
le fameux tina teyana there with no
beautiful mais il est aussi en réseau
sa noblesse à la chose politique et
dire cocotte habille-toi cocotte maquis
rester dans sa zone de confort escaut si
si nous par exemple chercheurs on avait
pays qui n'intéresse donc plus est très
comme art majeur et ça devrait nous
c'est très important à avoir aussi et
petit peu moins là il faut vraiment
la mer à la
sisyphe l'impasse comme un gros compte
aussi c'est peut-être une vanne ogien
latinas etc et je trouve que c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya de la blood 100 ici
2017 alors je les accepte et alors
le cadre même supérieur qui de toute
nous faire voir est ce que l'europe tels
pédagogie les gens ne comprennent pas
même de la revendication
mieux arriver à en rire quand même parce
nous oblige à faire ça
qui sont institutrice qui sont
haut de ses 85 ans ou je sais pas quoi
grandement comment ça va ça va pas mal
les représentations communes voilà
grand soutien de maquereau en revanche
c'est ce qu'on appelle donc la
en plus il est pris sur des affaires ou
et c'est pour ça que je veux pas non
plutôt radicale tout ce genre de choses
technologies à leur disposition elles
compris que finalement c'est bien le
pour la ctkd politique mais à tous les
infrastructures étasunienne il faut pas
réglementée par les états donc les donc
je m'aperçois que je suis une périphérie
démocratie mais aussi de lumière tu vois
on parlait peut-être de radicalité tout
trappes à pauvreté les trappes hexion
case
blanc et qui ne boit pas et cheval blanc
point de vue là est quelque chose de
je mettrai aussi à l'actif des
donc est ce que là il n'ya pas des
donc on voit bien que c'est grâce à cela
la légion d'honneur en temps aussi que
beurre s'il te plait pas small cell tu
après nous en tant que chercheur on a
accès à quelques données ça pourrait
qui est qui est assez
rapport à la médecine à deux trois
desquels j'ai aussi beaucoup travaillé
pour le coup mais mais mais voilà les ça
amener là au contraire comme les
en bon
très perturbé par cela l'économie
que tellement c'est dramatique
mais ils ne comprennent pas quoi
aussi du web de la fabuleuse aussi bull
alternative on n'a pas le choix on
l'instant en impesanteur c'est aussi la
la gestion finalement du havre a
que les gilets jaunes font c'est
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
plus leur jeter comment la pierre à mes
toi cocotte mets toi à poil sur les
et on va arriver vers vraiment comme
elle paraît plus jeune que ma fille kahn
à force finalement d'être cette caste
et voilà et une tutoie et donc me tutoie
aujourd'hui qui pourrait faire tellement
trop bizarre trop fumeurs de la vallée
je pense que plutôt que l'injonction à
ou les femmes et les hommes d'origine
cette oligarchie elle a le savoir pour
mais il ya de la transparence un peu
qu'ils se rendent compte 1 mais même moi
seul point et lequel j'étais d'accord
vitesses et compagnie
qu'on les laisse tomber et c'est donc
très important et c'est vraiment le
comme ça de dire alors on plus
donc cesser je reprend la parole c'est
que on l'a aujourd'hui conçu c'est à
les trappes à pauvreté c'est quoi c'est
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya des
que vous faites pour les autres je suis
n'y a pas que ça c'est être un bon
c'est ça c'est ça tirait le sien alors
appelle choix ah oui on va vite
vraiment fabuleux il ya des femmes de
mais l'état entreprises vraiment danser
est ce que vous connaissez la chaîne
politiques certainement
blagues racistes comme les blagues
on voit bien que là on est au coeur du
vois donc ils n'allaient pas non plus
passionnant quand même de voir c'est
deux dans une société qui voit de plus
mise l'éducation nationale puisque je
qu'on peut dire les femmes sont payées
parce que avec ses fameuses milices on
choses intéressantes au front national
je veux dire je mets ce que je disais là
être intéressant je vais prendre
façon doit travailler et vie du fruit de
quelle est la rationalité économique qui
théories queer
hétérodoxes c'est quoi c'est cette
à leur parlons de violence
j'aurais trouvé ça vraiment magnifique
avec manuel valls dans ma vie c'est
plus il pourrait faire tellement plus
besoin d'argent pour cela il l'a aussi
font sécession au niveau de
tata dans les écoles comme on les
politiques qui avait été choisi comme
de lumière on veut aussi mais même moi
c'est
consoeurs et mes confrères chercheurs
politiques qui gouvernent aujourd'hui ne
bien sûr vous ayez coup j'ai vu quoi
des choses cdc des pièges en fait dans
sexistes jeu j'avoue que j'ai assez peu
je suis une marge moi aussi mais
c'est très bien est-ce que c'est du
la réussite plutôt que l'injonction à
tellement vieux qu'il faut absolument
assez intéressant un philosophe
d'abord cette légion d'honneur arrive
politique et donc le politique s'il en
mieux avoir le pouvoir évidemment et
je dois me rendre compte aussi j'ai eu
l'infrastructure aussi d'éducation
plutôt invité en fait tout simplement
je voudrais aussi
grands pouvoirs la gale personnage
apparemment est en train d'être épinglé
quelques questions internet dont une qui
dans les barricades pour aller couper la
réseaux sociaux kockott fait du porno je
fait partie des choses qui existent
alors dans les représentations les
crois qu'on a compris mon métier c'est
toute la question sur le robot est ce
non
cette population
en plus vite hyperliens su qu'il ya un
qu'elle est parfaitement universel si
qu'ils entendent cj les jeunes qui
dire très large trop large trop large
moment où on ne scrawl plus et arrêter
ont bien joué les gars pour eux pour eux
plus qui s'y met aussi
voilà relire aussi je sais pas des
faire cette retraite jsf ouhlala les
24% en moyenne de moins que les hommes à
démocratique qu'est internet finalement
avant quoi donc c'est quand même aussi
j'y reviens la question des
manager jouer avec tout le monde ça
qui se regarde entre l est qui se
de gitanes et trop buveur de ricard
la violence allait aussi dans les mots
tête de liste aux européennes et j'ai
appelle
à l'antenne ce qui s'est rarement si
gens qui demandent certaines choses et
c'est à dire c'est ce féminisme en fait
quand il diagnostiqué l'apartheid social
peut nous obliger à faire ça je ne sais
un type qui est pas un révolutionnaire
économie qui dit on ne peut pas dire que
dans ce côté très
d'impact sur la retraite etc c'est
au front national
ça beaucoup de français l'ont doté cette
comment dire comme l'avènement de cet
d'olivia poupe qui est absolument
si à la périphérie et qui vient souvent
d'humour
j'ai été passionné il ya quand même des
pour venir là deux secondes à emmanuel
pipeau
aussi et qui sont peut-être plus subtil
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
son travail
apparaître peut-être justement pas
la chance aussi de vivre dans un milieu
raconté une autre illusion on a parlé de
n'a pas le droit d'avoir des amis qui
laquelle à un moment donné duquel tu ne
le terrain ça coûte cher
puisque évidemment tout ce beau monde va
très sérieusement pour ce qui en plus il
nounou qui sont celles qui vont
heureusement peut-être aussi qu'il ya
pourquoi parce que déjà j'arrive de ma
je ne sais pas est ce que toi tu vois
imaginaires
qui est mort je crois qu'il ya un an ou
est-ce que c'est du pipeau je pense que
et pas de ses actions vous voyez c'est
a été posée 7h20 depuis cette anicroche
veulent pas entendre parler de ça ils
fabuleux aussi dans une série dont j'ai
avait la volonté
un jour je reçois un courrier papier
poste égal et c'est donc aujourd'hui
tu as bien compris et être proche du
par exemple par exemple qui considère
comme rifkin d'accord
tête entre guillemets du maire en
le discours dupont aignan je ne connais
vais te prostituer etc etc ils ont passé
infrastructures
american psycho en fait de bresse saône
c'est que j'ai aussi beaucoup beaucoup
la violence allait dans les mots
j'ai vu pas mal de géopolitique j'ai vu
c'est pas trop la coutume c'est pas ton
elle était universel mais elle prendrait
ses demandes elles viennent d'une certes
évidemment l'antisémitisme évidemment
passé des heures et des heures à écouter
l'enseignement est peut-être un peu plus
problématique plus voilà donc vous voyez
pas ça s'appelle du politique ça
complètement ni fait ni à faire aucun
capitaux vont partir il faut absolument
que le robot doit payer des cotisations
tube il ya plus de questions supermarché
drones le ton pour le temps de lire
pensent comme s'ils pensent comme ça non
peux plus sortir tu étais vraiment entre
macron lui ce qu'il a eu c'est les
déconnexion d'avec les petites
le cnrs aujourd'hui qui est en train
ça c'est quand même très étonnant c'est
de faire ça sur son écran comme ça pour
peut-être aujourd'hui
véritablement il pourrait tout à fait
province déjà
des territoires se déteste ce mot qui
où il y avait suffisamment d'argent pour
eux doivent
des boris johnson qui disent tiens
que les femen parce que les femen ont
on a l'impression qu'on a loupé quelque
justement c'était une mise en avant par
dominant
accompagner les gens fans vie eux qui
cautionnent trompe ou qu'ils cautionnent
reproduit mais qui se regarde la quête
deux assez récemment qui raconte aussi
va faire quoi sa campagne électorale à
sont dans une forme d'autorité politique
les entretiens et le travail qualitatif
burn out évidemment mais bon les les
oublié le nom et qui est une femme noire
le réformer etc il faut toujours
pas par coeur un et là j'ai découvert
enfin c'est quand même utile c'est quand
l'occurrence le chevalier à toulon à
écouté entendu
ça permet aussi de s'acheter peut-être
aussi que le capitalisme et le féminisme
l'illusion du de la non d'idéologie et
d'injonctions surtout pas surtout pas
dans des écoles privées depuis le plus
et 2,51 et donc je me suis retrouvé à
sait très bien que aujourd'hui l'état se
évidemment monique pinçon charlot
homme et de cette femme
trop large c'est à un moment donné parce
l'économie est complètement confinés
sans aucun problème j'ai pas les femmes
enfin je sais pas moi je ferai pas la
quand même très étonnant c'est pareil
souveraineté nationale maintenant il
les meilleurs c'est les industries
ou deux plus grands pôles monde mais
expressions politicienne de ce serait
même lui dit les infrastructures doivent
payer des études j'ai vécu aussi dans un
aussi et j'en suis désolé a tiré pour
s'appelle un choix politique puisque
que les deux mamelles du capitalisme
qui sont exactement
pas il n'est pas actionnaire il est
l'islamophobie
l'époque donc je voyais bien qu'il y
tijd véritablement de ses périphéries à
qui a des effets miroir elle peut penser
je ne suis pas paris 7eme paris 6e paris
quand tu es une femme
et liste des années 80 vous faire de la
peut-être sans le national ben oui oui
chose qu'on a loupé vraiment quelques
ap et en chasse et encastrer tu peut
partir de la notoriété du côté premier
réseaux dont le capital social dont on
changer le système et le donner de l'air
traiterait le cacheton pour teuling % il
alors c'est pas qu'ils roulent au diesel
acelino dupont taignons
absolument comme s'il n'y avait jamais
certains mouvements extrêmes
vient souvent des territoires et qui va
émancipée des carcans précédent et j'ai
autre chose
économiste digne de ce nom pourrait être
évidemment de la mode les âges aussi de
voire d' autoritarisme
qui arrive au sommet extrême sommet du
kraft et puis apparemment quelqu'un est
faut récupérer pour que justement on
pour
quelques petites choses il si vous
aller checker checker checker checker
même utile compter aujourd'hui les actes
introspective avec son moteur csssae et
roche un peu plus chercheurs que prof
bien sûr que c'est un endroit encore je
que les partisans plutôt d'une éthique
josy changer de logiciel dont le ca
font très mauvais ménage par exemple je
bien que le politique se reconnecter
une image on parle aujourd'hui beaucoup
alors j'ai aussi d'autres
aussi d'être battu violente et
trois bouquins pour d'autres communautés
pour le patron de tesla c'est pareil
voilées si elles ont envie de se voiler
là on peut se tutoyer mais le cadre tu
comme ça dans un congélateur et qu'elle
évidemment j'ai vu l'incontournable
parlait et après la finance et les
dans le même temps on baisse les appels
ça coûte une fortune
c'est la différence en anglais entre les
que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
c'est-à-dire alors le cadre supérieur
jeux j'ouvre justement une parenthèse
se recentre et
et qui fument des clopes et comme disait
avait un militantisme finalement assez
plus en sortir et ça ça coûte mais si on
aussi à la fin qu'elle détient la vérité
tue les yuppies aura tout ça mais mais
pour moi évidemment tout à fait oui
jamais jamais d'alternative et c'est
une fois les féministes attirer les
pour vraiment saisir les mécanismes
ou défilés ou pas de la république à la
soit peut-être moins soumis à la finance
me forme et bien sûr que c'est encore
évidemment ça ne fonctionne pas et ça
milieu dans lequel il y avait
sont très ou les plus tôt les deux
milice là dessus après
mais quand même quoi est donc finalement
lâchez dupont aignan qui m'ont
à tout ça et nous redonner de la liberté
minimale de l'état mais en revanche qui
l'extrême opposé de jeu fut bien juin
n'est pas le rang et n'est pas dans cet
ministre enfin c'est quoi c'est vraiment
prend pour une entreprise et c'est le
pouvoir à washington
qui on a dit pendant des années vous
amende et dominique de villepin dit ok
être maintenus dans un pays parce que
avec les gens qui mange avec les doigts
il est plus simple de balancer du
de greenwashing de gender washing social
jordan bardella
voir faire des selfs ivoire être dans ce
pourrais d'avoir son diplôme si
qui est en train de se faire fracasser
vous faire des statistiques ethniques
l'autorité
est hors sol
journalistes mais ce que c'était les
surtout du coup vous voyez les auteurs
homophobes c'est utile aussi alors vous
suffisamment de livres sur les murs de
possible hélas le politique en novembre
art
la médecine esthétique aujourd'hui de la
et quelle la lobbyiste absolue qui fait
gouvernement et le président que
benjamin griveaux dans il me semble
je dis pas que je suis absolument boggio
financièrement mis dans des fourches
de ce1 de 5 euros
vas être bien différent qui on s'est
pour tim cook s'est séparé en fait
vraiment je lance un appel parce que je
resterez à la périphérie vous y resterez
finalement interpellé voilà c'est bon
dans vos parenthèses
très étrange parce que nous en tant que
vous voyez c'est parlons juste des
bastille et sur les champs-elysées et
de salon et puis à côté il y avait un fn
d'autres principes
subtils saisir les mécanismes subtils et
pourrait m'expliquer maintenant à la
n'oublions pas sa n'oublions jamais ça
et tout ça on l'a bien vu c'est quoi les
l'économie c'est du social
comme réponse ça c'était plutôt du côté
féministes qui est qu'ils aiment et ce
par plein de moyens que j'ai annoncé
taf
c'est arrivé au bon moment et j'ai voulu
c'est véritablement problématique et
évidemment ça ça va sans dire non je
jambes du capitalisme aussi sont très
bruno gaccio of course j'ai vu un bout
plus grave parce que nous par exemple
c'est de l'hystérie
allez l'europe des 20 des 23 des 24 des
même les investisseurs aujourd'hui
j'ai déjà fait mais en juin ça avait
chirurgie esthétique c'est les
doit calculer l'efficacité économique
j'aime c'est vrai peut-être être dans
province et puis donc tout d'un coup je
par la mondialisation c'est ça c'est en
très peu l'oiseau parce qu'elle n'a pas
super super cooptés et les travaux boad
sais j'ai fait ma thèse sur le front
bien sûr oui moi je le pense vraiment à
prendre les gens mais pour plus bête
sondage le sondage c'est une machine qui
caudines aussi de cette mathématisation
beaucoup d' enthousiasme dans ce livre
narcissisme voir dans cette société
dont je vous ai parlé
travailler de cette manière là ça fait
les gens qui ne sont rien tout ça c'est
repenser soi-même avec soi même à les
beaucoup parlé en amont enfin ça n'a
levées de fonds donc peut-être un peu
dit que l'état sur ses fonctions
moi j'ai que j'ai écrit un bouquin en
la maison pour avoir un habitus culturel
véritablement à mon dieu qu'est ce que
2018 pouvait dire ok on a compris il ya
c'est pas forcément le premier que je
font-ils y répondent à d'autres gens qui
plus il y aura de l'autoritarisme comme
national donc je connais bien la faire
et c'est ça qui nous vont c'est-à-dire
chercheur ne serait-ce que ça mais j'ai
cherchais depuis quelqu'un a demandé la
tout à l'heure et notamment la
aussi un côté assez méprisant fin je le
qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent pour aider
qu'ils adorent investir sur la dette
qu'ils étaient attirés par les
recherche du coup voilà alors le
bien ancré sur les femmes d'un côté
et ça c'est pas les mêmes mais
industries évidemment de la pornographie
voyez évidemment à chaque fois il ya un
washing est-ce qu'on n'est pas aussi un
la pluie et le beau temps à washington
pourquoi donc ce qu'ils payent lisf ont
voulais parler d'une autre illusion
pauvre cadre même super supérieur qu'on
25 des 27 pourquoi pourquoi il élargit
kiki piétons en école enfin qui sommes
de chez benoît hamon regardons ce qui a
je le pense vraiment
donc ça c'est très très très très très
dans le choix de la main non plus
l'économiste et du politique et s'est
c'est quand même le symbole est fort
d'un pays puisqu'il n'y a que ça qui les
antibes au dos je raisonne je peux dire
classes de la classe politico médiatique
féministes ou par le fait qu'elle était
très longtemps ce devait être en
rien à voir
régaliennes
solutions si vous avez des
pourquoi il ya mathématisation parce
c'est dans la subtilité qu'est la
mettrais à ma table mais
aussi accélérer le temps pour que
deux ans qu'ils bossent sur quelque
sur les gens
sa politique qui vient du haut qui
la taille et l'oiseau n'a pas répondu
panoptique avec aussi une concurrence
peu le pendant voilà donc ans quand il y
qui on voulait et puis après les mêmes
féminisme et le capitalisme font mauvais
typiquement marie-hélène bourcier qui
j'avance ou que je marche c'est
de delphine batho qui est passé
qu'il ne sont et ce que je disais dans
légion d'honneur pour moi qui
2014-2015 j'écris en 2014 et je crois
vous faites vous organisez vous même
moins le savoir en tout cas il avait le
transparence de nos supers investisseurs
et je connais bien la faire et et
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné tu ne
en tant que chercheur je parle je parle
c'est de la neutralité de de l'illusion
de bien aussi si on veut faire du
donc je trouve que c'est c'est vraiment
comme instrumentalise pour qu'elle fasse
d'éluder la question se pose parce que
il me tutoie et il dit ah vous dis des
vraiment et beaucoup d'espoirs même si
indispensable doit être évidemment là il
résumé c'est ce que j'étais en train de
qui est pas 7 bat toujours cette classe
chose qui est juste inique indigne mal
française parce que nous sommes une très
piquer comme ça dans les bibliothèques
intéressent mais ça ça coûte des
troisième
comme ça grandement parce que
c'est les industries de la prostitution
petit peu là dedans moi je suis très
mon grand père était fan de théâtre tu
le fait ça va être dispatchés là où tu
leur ont rien demandé c'est quand même
récemment voilà et c'est comment va la
vois et là je m'aperçois de ce que c'est
c'est la question du mérite oui c'est la
encastré quand on décide de moins
efficacité décision management vérité
présentes à part par téléphone
qu'en fait il ya budget serré c'est
apparemment quelqu'un de la préfecture
vous fait sécession mais c'est bien vous
pour pour donner un peu d'eux et de leur
crois c'est qu'ils sont aussi obligés
qui
mon bouquin justement dont on parlait
compliqué alors heureusement là pour le
néanmoins ces gens sont quand même
dire c'est que de toute façon même ce
fracasse qui est borgne qui qui qui
ménage pourquoi alors d'abord parce que
peut peut être enviés parfois ou lui en
il ya aujourd'hui peut-être des pistes à
voilà je ne suis plus très drogue non
aux questions de bois 936 radicalité
savoir pas ou sont ce savant du terme
dans les journaux n'importe où n'importe
solution politique peut toujours une
du pouvoir d'achat il ya un prennent le
en école de commerce
benchmark politique comme mais ils
dit des choses fabuleuses parfois un peu
peux plus toi politiques dire aux
politologues ont beaucoup dit c'est
bonne dette mais on est une bonne dette
qu'il sort en 2015
lisez disaient nos productions pas la
quand les féministes sont pas déduits
milliards et des milliards d'euros nous
vu des chaque arrivée de 50000 euros
des humains et qu'elle donne la main aux
des bouches du rhône et qui
qui fait sécession à la fin oui vous
murder c'est pareil je trouve que c'est
d'abord c'est une forme d'irrespect tout
en marche il faudrait faire quoi il
cas de romain goupil il a été bien plus
principalement
extraordinaire donc ils vont voir les
en a certains qui utilise les
a aussi un travail sur les questions de
comme ça que la mathématisation
mimétique
pas en tant que dictateur vous avez bien
auraient beaucoup d'argent et heureux
on fait très attention à dire à nos
de l'universalisme
rapidement donc j'ai pas pu passer des
préparé mal communiqué donc à un moment
tout à l'heure
conneries
cadre aujourd'hui et bien on lui demande
c'était assez rigolo najat marc omis
travailleraient dans le service des
des ça les intéresse quand même beaucoup
france en terme de dialogue plaisir des
d 1% dont on parlait au début c'est ce
évidemment je taquine évidemment la
enfin si c'est tout cela de la traite
pouvoir d'achat d'ailleurs il donne
appellent ça les biarrots gardons
juste en vote protestataire ils sont
aujourd'hui montre combien les
comment dans les films les séries dans
radicale pour certains mais qui sont ces
vouloir ou pour ceux qui paient pas
coupe des mains enfin c'est délirant
parenthèse
méritocratie à la française mais quand
sinon l'europe de l'est les europe de
arrivants et la matiz la mathématisation
la vraie bourgeoisie à la française et
le nom s'appelle ce monde qui nous
périphéries reste à la périphérie non
tu dis des conneries ouais donc tu
veux union européenne située train
pourquoi on est une bande est parce qu
convaincu de ce qu'il raconte pourquoi
le capitalisme pour deux raisons
heures avec elle passait des heures avec
lège bien descendu suis-je plus beau
on avait calculé
cet universalisme qu'on nous vend matin
n'êtes pas complètement idiot vous allez
moins et on n'arrive pas à faire la une
compris mais heureusement je vous
fortune mais pour le bien commun pour
humains
mais il savait toquer aux bonnes portes
édiles municipal
ce monde qui nous échappe je disais bien
étudiants mét et du politique dans le
mienne les miennes en particulier de
mensonge des choses comme ça non la vie
d'accord avec aucune idée mais non
fabuleux maintenant dans les séries ce
aller regarder est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
assez d'impôts mais il fait partie des
faudrait arrêter de sélectionner les
cadeaux et les étudiants
hystérique que moi donc je suis plutôt
beaucoup d'argent mais cet argent voilà
puisqu'il ya plus d'idéologie on
entreprises
la santé de la maladie qui est assez
dire voilà il ya tant de naissance de
simplement
jusqu'où violence anarchisme et bottes
jusqu'en fin de vie de manière mal
donné cette illusion de démocratie cette
les bd est sûre tous écoutent et écouter
le coût donc économique des
quand même cédé liant ce qu'on est en
cette légion d'honneur en fait en plein
le sont ils à ce point là juste par
ce que ce qu'en fait la classe ouvrière
tout oublié
qui veut côtoyer le bonjour c'est ce
express états unis etats unis afrique
question de la démocratie l'esoc de
vois enfin j'ai aussi vécu dans un
les marges
des humaines principalement je dis pas
on a un chemin de fer parce qu'on a des
droits des femmes
aussi elle permet
tu sais qu'à alix à polytechnique à
trajectoires de vie et de réussite
m'aime moi je reprends le vouvoiement
pourrait prendre ces bonnes idées un
demande mais en tant que dictateur ça
thala la prise de contrôle de la
cette série c'est une vieille histoire
des inrocks quand on n'est pas à poil
que je trouve aussi c'est peut-être la
les maires locaux les municipalités et
vers lesquels je peux me tourner ici ou
quittent interdisent de faire ça qui te
essentielles le capitalisme d'abord a
challenges et ça qui va encore aller
pourrait pas avoir des agences de
l'est risque est en fait de tomber dont
échappent et surtout le sous titre c'est
l'intérêt général pour le social c'est
n'importe quoi moi je voyais bien aussi
gens qui sortent des grandes écoles qui
passionnant ruwen ogien
là tout le monde est fils de journaliste
aussi voilà les gens de la france a
parties prenantes il fait pas partie des
voilà et ça j'ai du mal j'ai du mal
jean extra européens ou quant à zemmour
déménagement parce qu'il a fallu faire
personne ne vous répond donc vous voyez
mais nous sommes éclairé aujourd'hui
midi et soir est une illusion absolue
qu'ils veulent côtoyer et qui veulent
milieu quand même qui m'a déjà donné
train de vivre plus il y aura sa plus
sorti gagnant de cette affaire mais il
opportunisme dont il faut arriver à
j'ai demandé à deux trois personnes que
est ce que tu veux ou bien tout
plus belle qu'elle plus efficace est le
d'abord on sait pas exactement où ils et
il savait où était les réseaux il savait
rémunérés ou pas rémunéré du tout où ou
tellement j'ai l'habitude de vous voyez
chai partout et chez tout le monde et
politique et la france d'en bas la
discriminations liées aux origines
est complexe on ne managent pas des
qu'il ya pas d'homme dedans il y en a
légitimité de nos dirigeants déjà à
notation alternatives qui pourraient
prennent l'action et disent moi aussi je
sont sélectionnés depuis la maternelle
sa petite voix je crois qu'on a tous une
écoles parce qu'on est des draps des
qui sont souvent qui paye assez rarement
je suis encore de ceux et de celles qui
limite à part son rôle du new black je
dernière fin 2019 de ce gouvernement
disent tu ne peux pas écouter cette
je connaissais là bas elles m'ont dit
coiffe
la radicalité électorale est elle encore
avoir les codes des très hauts des
très étonnant alors oui bon monsieur
aussi un mais les pourcentages sont très
les finançons pas là les financements
ethniques c'est sale c'est sierre 6 1
les gens plateau donc tu dis des
besoin
très vite parce qu'évidemment
j'aime faire comme certains auteurs
l'illusion
comprendre aussi pourquoi il est
simplement la france et après tu va
quelques codes et pourtant pourtant
illusion politique et cette illusion due
cetera macron fait son grand show il
l'ena ou à sciences po paris dont je
professionnelle sont quasiment
je vais me faire chambrer par hun sen
puis regardons aussi ou front national
plus de like plus de followers et j'en
soumises des verts
auprès de ses électeurs front national
où était l'argent et comme il à
là à ce qu'elle à ce que leurs leur
chercher ces gens finalement plus
et la classe la plus démunie a pu
il faudrait quoi
hôpitaux est parce qu on a des systèmes
france qui mange avec les doigts la
l'époque bien entendu mais voilà je dis
pour un universalisme des différences
des femmes et du travail silencieux des
nous sommes éclairé stop on ne peut plus
que tu vois à la télé tout le monde est
personne là tu ne peux pas l'entendre tu
évidemment il y aura des réponses
dit voilà sur les violences faites aux
soyez pas le manager des bills les
aussi
la poche de la russie c'est pour ça
c'est pas moi donc je ne sais pas donc
ya aussi ce problème c'est que une femme
sont ne sont pas là pour l'instant etc
à 10 milliards d'euros par an 10
conneries et ses opus bon il me fait un
si nous étions dans un système
voilà c'est ça est-ce que c'est pas
points très dur de certaines banlieues
trouve que la pauvreté et peut regarder
de toute façon l'autre branche c'est
citoyens parce que si on manage des
petite voix moi je donne aucun conseil à
voilà
l'illusion de la neutralité
on voyait bien qu emmanuel macron allait
travailler avec wwf avec greenpeace est
dorment l'argent débarque un dans la
envisageables pour changer les choses en
inégalitaire entre les hommes et les
quand tu débarques comme ça dans cet
est-ce que vous certains auteurs qui
passe et des meilleurs donc la lecture
il disait moi je ne suis pas d'accord
et j'en passe
alors j'allais venir chez acelino je
sors
lisf je dois avouer on précarité extrême
alors il me dit tu es vieux tu es vieux
aujourd'hui par exemple un benoît hamon
personne est ce que nos politiques se
france des ronds-points france qui a du
radicales et dictature de faible
déterminer dès l'école maternelle je dis
énormes que l'audition éditions de
saison qui qui seraient en manque
facebook s'amuse avec sa crypte aux
années 80 on n'arrête pas de leur dire
qui tiennent bien qu'on a une justice
veux en être et c'est intéressant aussi
tombe la chemise ils s'écoutent parler
connaître il ya 20 ans dix ans par
disent que quand même le politique doit
quand on décide de moins soutenir les
jupiter et de saturne mais cette classe
fils de diplomate d'ambassadeur de
qui d'autre oui j'aime ça j'aime
femmes c'est entre les lignes c'est là
traiter en fait du chiffre ça va aller
mais cet argent
quoi c'est la femme en tant qu objet de
peu deux fois donc c'est toujours
ne peux pas le recevoir tu ne dois pas
femmes pour le coup et là tout d'un coup
donné des lames de rasoir ou prochain
c'est un logiciel qui est complètement à
penser que nous sommes le peuple des
femmes moins cher ou le travail non
profondeur
enfin absolument mais je pourrais h pour
assez dur qui elle le demande même plus
la demande s'est fait comme ça et puis
non idéologique ne peut pas durer et
citoyens moi qui ai par exemple handicap
élevage justement qui va après se
mal à remplir le frigo la france qui y
c'est le temps où tout ça s'arrête et on
jeu sky devant lui devront commander
et peut observer comme si elle n'était
utilisent des drogues pour partir au nom
qui a un peu d'autorité qui dit stop qui
qu'on se précipite en fait sur l'europe
et c'était très intéressant benoît hamon
mes étudiants aujourd'hui je crois que
universel
avec les valeurs de l'islam je ne suis
certainement être élu il fallait vie de
l'aube voilà 2015
pendant deux trois quatre cinq six sept
etc tout ça c'est quand même du service
penchent sur ce genre d'écrits non je ne
qui fini à 6 % je pense que ces princes
justement ces effets de les premiers
ça nos étudiants soyez conscient soyez
chômeurs qu'est ce qui se passe on fait
intensité a bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
combien même s'il était arrivé
veux pas cacher le fn mais j'allais
d'empathie
quelque chose les les marges et les
monnaies en disant on va peut-être
comme ça après c'est les féministes il
et c'est ça qui est redoutable alors que
mesure où aujourd'hui il ya ce lien
honnêtement vous tapez nous franchement
bien dès l'école maternelle
qui a été de santé précaire et karelia
pantoufles et palce et de palais en
alors est-ce que ça passe par des
trois films a alors trois films alors
milliards d'euros par an et je dis ça on
ce qu'on pourrait pas aussi être
rien à l'état elles vont même plus des
années 70 65 ans qu'est ce qui va se
le recevoir parce que cette personne là
très vite et tu vas faire des grandes
il n'y aurait pas de médecine à trois
montrer un peu d'exemples sur le commun
j'ai un peu laissé filer laisser couler
toujours aussi cette posture a précisé
alors là moi j'utilise ma drogue alors
séduction et qui va jusqu'à la traite
pas d'accord avec ces jeunes même de la
depuis quelque temps je fais quoi je
où il ya le plus d'immigration plus de
public ou parapublic de toute façon mais
pouvoir
dit non je sais voilà je sais ce que
revoir yao kan
c'est
c'est tellement difficile il ya
souvent elle croit elle croit vraiment à
innovant voyez j'ai donné plein de
rémunéré des femmes ou très peu
heures vous savez nous on tourne prof
bossent
grands professeurs d université et
en parler aussi et
pas télégénique voilà je dirais qu'il ya
recommence à tourner des pages en fait
complètement admettons ces milliards
ya christine delphy aussi que que j'aime
reproduire
des managers citoyens on entendait la
soit balle à l'écran soit belle sur
jeudi par le collège le lycée c'est dès
de santé de retirer de l'eau je suis
moi j'ai aucun problème avec ce mot
j'estime aujourd'hui on peut même je
palais c'est à dire de palets de
socialiste parti socialiste je pense que
aujourd'hui ça c'est en train de faire
aussi que j'oubliais dans l'eau et
entre je travaille pour avoir un salaire
beaucoup aussi tout ce qui arrive des
avoir un rapport de force avec eux la
actions est ce que ça passe par des
c'est terminé ça ne sert à rien il ya
venir celle à ses vidéos pain en parisis
masses c'est grand mas en plus elles
d'ailleurs ça ne marche pas et
en tant que chercheur je vous assure qu'
peut-être 20 ans j'en donnais beaucoup
pauvreté c'est là qu'ils les violences
pistes un complément différentes les
ça c'est une drogue dure à attention je
parce que c'est pas trop ma came en
n'importe quel étudiant de socios de
filets il se demande pourquoi à chaque
des êtres humaines et qui va évidemment
se penchent sur les travaux académiques
alors alors j'ai adoré le machin la cour
évidemment à l'infini entre entre eux
deuxième génération ils n'ont qu'à
cetera et tout d'un coup tu es tout
si nous étions dans un système universel
il faut être radical on n'est pas au
ce qui ne se voit pas à l'écran depuis
passer deux minutes là dessus je fais
c'est vous savez
suis un citoyen out alors parce que dans
débloqués 3 10 ans
rothschild à palais de l'elysée bon
une fois qu'on aura cassé toutes ces
c'est pas que je sais dans l'absolu mais
un tsunami absolument sûr tout le monde
sur le respect de tous je crois la
tout simplement au lieu de scrollé
c'était pas juste par opportunisme qu'il
d'ailleurs ça ne marche pas donc cesser
en boucle carrément pas mais chez
absolument son dompter les routes avec
n'est pas très impressionnés quand on
s'était un calcul
unes des autres
cultural studies alors c'est stuart hall
plus qu'aujourd'hui
vraiment c'est on constate quand même
rémunérés des femmes mais qui prennent
pourrais même peut-être dîner avec cette
beaucoup et que je lis beaucoup
question écologique en entendait la
rentrer chez eux l'histoire éternelle et
faites aux femmes
cette photo va te faire photoshopée
ce qu'elle dit c'est à dire que par
on voit qu'il y a
fois vous rappeler ça a été la grande
ah il faut faire des économies il est
fais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
certainement ce problème là et cette
blogs chain agences de notation
infrastructures qu'on aura foutu tout ça
jusqu au jeunisme etc etc etc donc ce
l'école maternelle donc c'est d'une
vont être achetés par les journaux parce
c'était très intéressant de voir la
sciences po déco quoi que ce soit à
mais je ne peux pas spéculer sur mon
tout petit je
sauf sur ce évidemment qui sont pas
non je ne le crois pas ils attendent que
le
cc c'est à double tranchant aussi non
est dans des amphis 300 400 étudiants et
on aurait dit plein de choses mieux plus
une parenthèse et après je viens à la
une entreprise non compréhensive qui n'a
ça s'appelle le prix parasites
question femmes hommes entendent et les
puisque c'est une reproduction du nom du
méditation
a fini à 6 % au contraire par
plus le monde se complexifie plus c'est
en tout cas j'ai travaillé sur tel ou
réellement
acelino par exemple quand il dit malgré
et par exemple nous on a défini ce qui
scrollé scrollé et ça c'est très
qui était statique c'est à dire qu'on
des conditions aussi pour faire leurs
petit petit petit petit dans danseuse
forcément les codes il les avait je
ressembles à ton photoshop etc et on est
c'est c'est aussi on peut parler de
des gens qui nous ont reproché d'avoir
temps des réformes
crainte des médias et du folk et du
comme il n'y a pas deux
il n'y aurait pas des gens qui se sont
penser en première année un sondage tu
indispensable de faire des économies
en l'air notre dette sera t-elle
sa balle juste laisse poser tes
ne fais pas à mettre 80 je te le
tel sujet voilà je crois savoir voilà on
quasiment et surtout dans les très
question là et il ya sûrement des séries
soin j'adore le travail de nancy frazer
politique et je prends la politique
prospective je vois mes étudiants moi
pense que
là tu leur répondait alors encore plus
exemple typiquement sur les questions
études très compliqué parce que derrière
différente souveraineté nationale plus
opportunisme il aurait pu raconter tout
caste du 1 % ou déjeuner ou prendre un
que que ça va vraiment excessivement mal
parce qu'aussi je vous raconte ma vie
fait se saisir se saisir des moments se
invité x ou y défilent bateau parce que
le travail académique soient digérées
et puis finalement
travail on est tous aujourd'hui c'est
que les journaux vont pouvoir titré 60%
précarités entendez le handicap entendez
sont des industries qui valent des
comme s'est pas accompagnée d'un
important
j'ai bien compris je crois avoir répondu
mais derrière ça coûte très cher cette
à un moment donné
pas envie de jouer avec le handicap ou
le fait qu'il ait fait un une petite
bouquin de bourdieu la reproduction mais
on peut aussi le dire comme ça on est
pense d'ailleurs que macro on devrait
de ses de ces machines intellectuelle
qu'on à 9 heures de cours il faut que ça
aujourd'hui un bon là on à la 3è 4è
ça passe par
donc la lecture voilà déjà c'est un
comme un art majeur
on est autant de la radicalité en tout
apadooraï qui travaille aussi sur
sang qui flotte comme ça au dessus de
quand même la sensation qui le fait plus
parasites en rien aux films coréens
pas tout à fait intégrés à cette
avait juste prix la
aussi dans une un beauf une arête de
difficile de savoir de quoi après après
précisément si on avait eu droit à ces
de leurs 35 heures 40 heures ou 50
autre chose donc il était certainement
confirme et donc si tu veux il fait deux
importantes ou pas
l'écris comme tu veux je veux dire voilà
grands corps d'état je veux pas dire 100
que j'adore encore plus que ce que j'ai
droit pour parler du brouhaha médiatique
commentaires de prospective ça nous
dans cet aéropage comme ça de gens
toujours aussi attractive c'est pas sûr
quand elle dit alors je le dis en france
économiques eh bien eh bien elle croire
sur digérer / / / / digérer et qui soit
milliards et des milliards d'euros et
j'ai commencé à faire court il ya une
discours politique d'inclusion
tu dois parfois bosser tu tombes malade
tout ça le temps pour ça et à côté bien
tu vas tu auras contre tout à l'heure
thé ou un café ou une bière
véritablement majeur et j'y tiens
prend ça aussi souvent ou des colères
je ne sais pas quoi comme notre problème
est profondément mal et c'est très
peut-être nous servir à l'avenir je
des gens soutiennent la grève 80% des
99% définitive et c'est là où je trouve
le nazisme était excessivement bien
l été c'est leur convenait pas où le mec
convaincu de ses robots de son écologie
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs à à sciences po
d'accord donc tu vois c'est pour de
plus de transparence dans cet anonymat
cités mais que j'oublie mes mais voilà
tier 1 an et on tombe l'agent du gardien
nous
bouffer évidemment évidemment autour du
génération rentrer chez eux ça va
comment on fait les marges et les
saisir de pouvoir ont fait ce que la
république parce qu'elle est quand même
juste sublissime absolue parfait rien à
les breloques oui les breloques enfin tu
discriminer maintenant on n'avait pas
cas elle est nécessaire elle est
vingtaine d'années quelque chose comme
pour lui et son enrichissement personnel
est un elle dit les femmes créent des
demain sera fait que va-t-on faire avec
c'est à dire qu'évidemment on comprend
% mais des gens bien nés on sait que
économie de aujourd'hui coûte très cher
en effet un logiciel qui mute qui permet
emmène ou parce que nous nous on a une
parce qu'il ya quand même de la machine
statistiques ethniques ça fait longtemps
heures parce que voilà les cadres sup
qui se font alors là non pas sur le dos
eh bien elle me met dehors c'est aussi
sûr quelques temps maintenant et non
de respect de regard de l'autre mais
commencer à être très compliqué parce
tu après les chiffres jeudi est ce que
mauvaises raisons
bananes ont que faire finalement de
en fait ça a été quand est ce que les
finalement qui portent des noms qui
on a été élevé pour détester deux
cou tune fait enlever des codes et dans
instant philosophique tout simplement
ou anciens de l'usr a pour un salaire
ça à l'époque je savais tout je savais
du tout et comme aujourd'hui on est
un best-seller mais c'est pas ça le
vraiment nécessaire c'est à dire que
très surplombante une et indivisible
intellectuelle derrière et c'est parfois
rappelle-toi la colère froide de
que certains chercheurs qui travaille
mais je voudrais que ce 1 % disent je
beaucoup
l'intelligence artificielle que va-t-on
et j'en passe et des meilleurs donc il
tu vois on dit tous les deux la même
inquiétant
qu'ils vont faire en fait un saut
qui détient la dette donc si déjà on
que pour x millions voire milliards de
était à droite ça leur convenait pas où
mais à côté je vais je les vient ton
vraiment que
voulais faire un peu de prospective
fois aussi en largeur et en hauteur et
communauté qui
périphéries ce comment dire ce alors à
humains oui c'est pas qu'elle l'ait créé
gens trouvent que 40% disent que etc et
de la classe ouvrière comme le
et là c'est mettre la politique en
cumuler les problèmes médicaux les
bien que ça peut être à double tranchant
tu sais enfin est évidemment alors qu'un
derrière et c'est ça que l'économie non
des mash ans je sais pas quoi je me
parce que c'est comme justement si cette
vas je m'aperçois que les gens font
l'éducation nationale donc pourquoi est
chose ça reste de toute façon pour deux
may à nancy fraser aussi des féministes
philosophe judith butler appelle la jane
sont rarement aux 35 heures mais c'est
quel que soit ce qu'on lit à la limite
école de commerce à je me sentais bien
parce que j'ai le travail que j'ai que
périlleux arrière pour retomber sur leur
calme dans ce monde des investisseurs
je trouve qu'à l'avenir est ce qu'il
ségolène royal qui l'a fait perdre
travail académique le trike anémique il
le mec était à gauche ça leur convenait
justement sur les exclusions des
vraiment très active dans la vraiment
le logiciel ne va pas c'est le logiciel
ceux qui ont fait l'école alsacienne
faire avec les crypto monnaie que
portent des noms et c'est marrant parce
c'était un management voilà
faut comprendre il faut donner aussi un
auteurs michel foucault et bourdieu
mais à force d'être une et indivisible
mais c'est vrai que je ne veux pas
de muter qui permet pas d'aller réformée
qui n'est pas celui combien je gagne
travaillait à cela ça me paraît être par
pas la question mais non parce que voilà
dire que être sûr qu'il croit ce qu'il
quand il était tout petit auront
capitalisme classique évidemment mais
est comme ça et mais c'est souvent aller
très riche d'aller regarder
sauf que les foréziens je suis surtout
remets toi des cheveux enfin je ne sais
je peux continuer à travailler et que je
au sens biologique elle les éduque elle
pas il y à vraiment je vais j'ai des
quasiment sa présidentielle et on dit
c'est donc quelque part toute la chaîne
ce qu'ils se battraient pour l'éducation
jaune pour encore plus qu'assez de
pour de mauvaises raisons cette affaire
va-t-on faire avec l'écrit elle est
si c'est à dire on prend en fait le
propre patte parce qu'évidemment ils
faudrait pas remanier la constitution
hyper classe comme vous dites ou c'est
libérale raconte elle raconte que le
c'est même pas ma question c'est pas je
discriminations liées aux origines où la
c'est que du mépris c'est genre tu n'as
tout et j'étais sûr qu'il ne savait rien
dessous de tout puisque la politique
est super riches déjà qu'aujourd'hui
qui nous regardent très haut en dix ans
aujourd'hui qui disent ça aussi on voit
prem's écologie que les problèmes de mal
raconte ah oui au jeu en tout cas non là
entretien notamment enfin moi je
et bien n'a pas pu souvent toujours
tout le spectre et nous tiennent au
ils dépendent de leur travail ça c'est
nationale ils n'en n'ont pas l'usagé
comprends j'entends j'ai de l'empathie
justement là bloc chase que va-t-on
suis dans un environnement très
monde ait la chance à chacun maintenant
monuments dans paris mais les banlieues
de toute façon donc on élargit on
beaucoup de chance et plein de plein de
pas quoi et est là et puis aussi
pour demander à ce que le président la
que moi je faisais quand même partie
des lettres je les défends pas je suis
qui va pas on peut changer trois
zemmour c'est pas le politique contre
pas me demander ça tu n'as pas à venir
de ci de là à faire des petits
sont français donc on veut envoyer quand
voilà par exemple avec avec ce break
elle leur donne les codes sociaux elle
travaille beaucoup évidemment il ya déjà
qui se font aussi sur le dos de la
question des banlieues par rapport au
nous en tant que chercheur au souffre
je passais des heures et des heures sur
vraiment très important ils ne sont pas
logement et c'est donc tout ce que cela
d'un milieu plutôt aisé en province et
favorable professionnellement mais dans
rapport à la question ça me paraît être
de valeurs financières se complaît dans
c'est un truc hallucinant moi
courant de leur valeur de ce qui se
sur qui on va investir aujourd'hui un
absolument fabuleux les premières écoles
chômeur moins indemnisés - suivi moins
pouvoir de l'autre et on le fait sien
heureusement ou pas je ne sais pas sarko
faire avec les robots partout quel
dont ils parlent
dedans c'est toujours ça que monde pour
veux dire que ce soit ceci ou cela c'est
1% aujourd'hui il ya de plus en plus un
nombreuses opportunités pour aller faire
je parlais du brouhaha médiatique
ajustements du gender washing social
j'ai mon vote je pars en vacances avec
république
centre les périphéries les marges etc ça
je je j'ai envie de collaborer à tout ça
élargit on s'y perd un peu bruxelles du
classe des femmes qu'il a et l'as nancy
me le demander au contraire c'est de la
calculer le coût économique des
la condition préalable en fait travaillé
pas pour l'instant
ils n'en ont pas l'utilité
du côté du capital ils sont
soit
même qu'il y avait quelque chose
serre-moi sexuellement serre-moi
énarques par ci deux polytechniciens par
induit il avance on n'avait pas pris
passe de ce qui se voit deux de ce qui
les insère dans la société et c'est ça
aussi hein parce qu'on a aussi un des
aime bien quand ils sont un peu
elles elles ont vraiment fait sécession
des travaux célèbres qui ont travaillé
ses bouquins de michel feher qui est
système social est ce qu'on va et de
p c'est quoi c'est vraiment tisser du
chez pas la légitimité chez max weber ce
heureusement que j'ai redécouvert comme
site aujourd'hui ça parle aussi voyez on
un étang entreprises normalement je suis
d'accord nous n'avons pas de pouvoir
pendant cinq ans c'était quand même
ils peuvent faire sans et puis
washing du greenwashing et tout ce genre
d'accord pas des politiques les
soutenu qu est ce qui va se passer
corpulent jouer aussi de l'autorité
discriminations liées aux origines parce
véritablement du côté du travail et ça
pas le problème quoi mais se poser voilà
là elle est si à londres pour aller
élu de manière locale au moins une fois
là évidemment mais vraiment c'est le
de management en allemagne se sont
j'étais plutôt donc la bonne élève du
de tendues avec la question musulmane
mais voilà ces statistiques en tout cas
sexuellement n'oublions pas la
coup évidemment ce se sert et se
quelque chose aussi un en terme
génial moi j'adore ce bouquin qui est le
au qui ont été là dessus soyez
demande de politique enfin c'est comme
de travaux qui sortent sur ce 1 % c'est
obligations de publication le le monde a
aussi tu vois autre chose aussi les
notamment chez les sociologues
j'en avais envie ses auteurs absolument
c'est du travail caché dont le
politiques savent très bien qu'ils font
et non plus de demande à l'état elles
toitures tu conseillerais de faire quel
deux d'or c'est terminé
fait très longtemps qu'on look on le
frazer par exemple le dit très justement
déjà à assainir et à reprendre le
ceux qui n'ont pas de pouvoir et c'est
de choses dont il faut vraiment être
qui je veux j'ai ma vie intime c'est ce
faire harvard pour aller faire cambridge
cette mathématisation
qu'on ne fait pas de statistiques
lien entre les gens c'est recréer ce
physique 1
au projet commun tu vois en fait c'est
pathologie c'est des pathologies
évidemment ces mêmes aussi
c'est la grande grande différence et ce
c'est redonner du temps au temps parce
entretient de bons directif d'entretien
temps d un v6 on est chacun un investi
du politique et que ce soit et que ce
inspirés du nazisme de sa manière de
genre de truc j'ai passé des heures
prostitution dans laquelle il ya les
réclame un nouveau gage de cela c'est
ont compris tête alors donnerait rien
une demande c'est pas de légitimité
conséquences sur la famille
ethniques en france du
vraiment tendu surtout dans les zones
nous pas pour dénoncer quand même ce don
capitalisme
job aujourd'hui c'est tellement
voyez si on casse tout à la fin si on
caricature est donc finalement ce break
dans le féminisme pour 99 % des femmes
un pur sang complètement déconnecté et
l'infrastructure aussi basiques que
pour aller faire sciences po paris lena
milieu aisé de provence et tu te rends
des voix qui s'élèvent en disant faites
très intéressant et
donc voilà ça joue de l'autorité
radical moi je les ai vues sur la
logiciel qui ne va pas de logiciel il
capital est parti très loin et très haut
de nos métiers
psychologiques ou on a fait un bouquin a
contrôle sur ses finances folle pour
réseaux de drogue qui sont connexes
non directifs c'est presque ce que tu es
patriarcale à ultra besoin sinon comment
tu vois et tout ça mais c'est d'amy est
avant d'avoir été président avant de
donc c'est une
que le temps s'est accéléré
que marché dangereux c'est bien sûr non
difficile donc ça aussi c'est difficile
d'amour de reconnaissance
ça qui m'intéresse donc je fais un grand
physique comme ça et
planning nous on est arrivé plus ou
que j'appelle cette rupture
fait de la casse sociale partout et
non plus moi que j'ai expérimenté
sont des dons non non non on contracte
qu'elle est l'investisseur qui veut
question du féminisme la question du
l'x et j'en passe mais on voit bien que
là dessus tout d'un coup
parce qu'évidemment tu te constitue pas
lien c'est très important aller chercher
l'infrastructure routière par exemple
qui n'en a que faire de l'intérêt
faire d'organiser de manager de
épistémologique enfin c'est plutôt
attention à les super cadre où les
alors aujourd'hui sur sur trump bien sûr
et certains beaucoup encore beaucoup
considérablement c'est ce que le
en train de faire c'est-à-dire en fait
beaucoup que c'était le nord de la
après et en même temps de manière même
par l'inter duflot c'est râpé
est
ça buzz ça buzz parce que finalement les
en revanche vraiment se reposer entre
site est ce qu'il va pas nous faire voir
ce sont des décisions politiques je
qu'on commence à regarder non plus les
c'est la même seconde entreprise si
plusieurs qui s'appelle talents gâchés
le gouvernement assure cette histoire de
miser sur moi aujourd'hui en tant
briguer la présidence de la république
donc en statique c'est 10 milliards on
général du comment de la volonté
dürckheim qui ont parlé et pas moi dit
féminisme
distinguo je crois entre ce que je
enfin c'est pas possible de se taper 30
philosophe rosa disait très bien cette
il est construit autour de plein
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont moquent
il ferait pour voler comme ça en plein
et des hommes et elle dit aussi l un
cadres moyens et cetera qui sont
au fin fond des périphéries aux dents
hiérarchiser de donner des ordres etc
tu ne fait que relancer
l'exclusion c'est trappe à pauvreté
france aussi l'est donc on le voyait et
consubstantiel refaire du politique mais
il ya deux manières de l'apprendre on
moins on faire à part des billets
m'explique on dit
où on on chiffre de manière économique
macron débarque
votre patron votre boss soit patronne
qu'individu c'est vrai aussi en tant
soi et soi part peut-être le biais alors
êtres humains comme des citoyens mais
avant moi mais c'est il y a virginie
la méritocratie
complètement d'aller prendre des rues
comment veux-tu raconter ça si tu as pas
je pense vraiment qu'ils manquent hélas
en plein ciel ça ne serait pas possible
gillet jeunes louper selon moi un moment
générale d autres d'une façon plus
peut-être en haut de ses 99 % de toute
accélération du temps c'est de la folie
compliqué deux chercheurs mais c'est ici
buts par jour sans être drogué d'accord
pour cent à son flotte c'est pas la
considère être non éthiques est ce que
ça veut dire que c'est dans tous les cas
d'illusions d'abord d'illusions rapidité
c'est pas cela ça c'est du réseau des
l'apprend de manière cool compatible à
tu bon ça tu as fait un peu l'avocat du
on a vu aujourd'hui on a même un mark
eux vous reconnaît jamais par une
et tout d'un coup il n'est plus question
les pliures en fait de la société ceux
on arrête par exemple on change les sf
qu'entreprise c'est évident et en tant
si tout ce travail invisible non
comme quoi des consommateurs des actifs
la lecture s'arrête nous arrêtent et ça
peine d'en parler et elle dit très
des routes même des autoroutes à
je suis très sincère je suis en plein
jobard sur les violences policières
historique je dis bien historique
cesser ces outils là c'est comme
qu'etat évidemment puisqu'il faut
façon il bis aussi du déclassement il
dans tous les cas de la volonté
diable tu ne fait que relancer tu es
d'horizontalité il n'est plus question
justement que justement il ne faut pas
évidemment qu'il reste ça et bien
d'empathie là pour le coup avec les
c'est très important première chose
racheter les dettes et donc l'allemagne
l'époque des jets des hélicoptères on
je considère comme m du développement
c'est ça des actifs etc tu es plus actif
politique avance c'est à dire que si
vraiment un un miroir de ton interviewé
de démo assise politique il n'est plus
manuels je pense vraiment qu'ils
l'a vu à davos récemment donc là aussi
d'infrastructures finalement n'intéresse
plus du tout évidemment je parle même
pas du tgv du train là c'est vraiment
pour le bas peuple
donc c'est assez affolant c'est c'est
affolant ça ça fait peur et on voit
vraiment que c'est comme s'il était un
ballon mais ils ont coupé en fait le
fils et ils sont plus sur terre du tout
je peux me tue de parenthèses bien sûr
vous ouvrez ont présenté ce pardon à
combien par mois vous estimez leur
classe par classe c'est quoi ces 3000
5000 euros par mois 20 à 25 millions
euros par mois 50 mille euros par mois
100 mille euros par mois cc 75000 sais
combien c'est très élevé c'est très
élevé je fais une parenthèse dans la
parenthèse du coup parce que il me
semble et là dessus je rejoins vraiment
le lectra les récents travaux de tod sur
la question je crois que il faut mettre
dans cette classe finalement dans
laquelle les ouvriers et les ouvrières
[Musique]